for
all right so we're going to start off we
have three three um speakers two of
which are from um art AR labs and then
getting it right from the start
representative from there I'm going to
ask speakers to try to keep it to three
to five minutes um because there'll be
I'm sure there'll be questions from the
from the U panel so if we can have up
Alex and R you guys here didn't go to
the minutes thank you
Dy don't have anything else we need to
do
can hit your butt got is that better
there we go uh good morning members of
the commission Mr chairman uh my name is
Alex toia I'm the director of government
Affairs for artwolf Laboratories um we
are here today uh we thank you for the
opportunity to share a little bit more
about the importance of Laboratory
Testing in any cannabis program uh we're
here to be a resource to you um so we're
we're happy to answer any questions that
you might have we have a brief that the
staff has provided to you uh just kind
of going over all the different aspects
of Laboratory Testing some of the
lessons learned from other states um and
I myself am not a lab expert but I did
bring a subject matter expert with me uh
he is our our director of labs uh for
artwolf Laboratories and he is ready to
take any questions that might have again
we thank you for this opportunity and we
hope to be um a good resource to you for
the the process that you're going
through and um we know it's going to be
a long process and and certainly not
going to be over by December 1st uh but
we want to continue to be able to
support you as you move forward uh Ron
and uh again thank you for having us and
U the invitation to be here committee
members it's much appreciated I'm Ron
Brooks I'm as Alex said the lab expert
for artwolf labs uh I've been involved
in the legal cannabis industry since
2018 uh but my background is in in
Laboratories even before that in
clinical and reference uh laboratory
space so I've been around labs for a
long time
um and any questions that you may have I
will do my best to answer and uh provide
any guidance because we we know science
isn't always at the Forefront of all
this but it is definitely important for
um the safety of those in this state
that any legal product is tested so any
way we can help we're here to do so
thank
you so I I'll just start the
conversation around um so lab testing
the conversation we had in the last
meeting was a state run model you know
State Labs versus third party
independent Labs can you talk a little
bit about how you how that works in
other states and and that kind of aspect
sure um happy to answer that question
and and we did uh take a few notes from
the the last committee meeting or
commission meeting and um definitely
wanted to touch on that uh States as you
know with with can all things cannabis
are doing everything a little bit
different um but there are some models
that seem to be working um we do see a
lot of states have at least one
Reference Lab I think um you know that's
that's traditional and conventional
wisdom to have a spot checker on on
Independent third party Labs um we do
see a lot of success in some states
doing uh third party um Labs there's
also a lot of problems with that and
that gets down to the Regulation and
Licensing of those individual Labs uh
some of the uh requirements that they're
they're asked to do um as always in any
industry there's Bad actors um and some
of the problems that that are inherently
arise from overregulation um does get
passed to labs and and creates a
conflict directly with some of the
Growers and producers when that's their
customers and they have a reason to to
want to please those customers so we we
do want to certainly um advise and and
share some of those insights and and as
I referenced in the policy document that
we shared with you a lot of examples of
of um those types of occurrences
happening um with lab shopping and and
really creating that Dynamic we do see
some success with um with third party
vendors for States I think um as you
know in in New Hampshire and other
states sometimes going to a third party
for a vendor to get goods and services
can be a very successful model um as
long as you're holding that accountable
and in the RFP process you are ensuring
that the um the vendors are going to be
able to hold up to their side of the
contract successfully uh most recently
we did see in Oklahoma them divert from
that model where they had used a um a
third party vendor for their state
Reference Lab uh they had some problems
with that lab they weren't really happy
and satisfied with one what they were
charging um which I can tell you was is
a little astronomical um but also with
their their service and their turnaround
time so they have decided to go the way
of in-housing a state lab um to do all
of the the testing and third-party um
checks on on the rest of the labs uh
that I think does bring some some
challenges um setting up a lab and Ron
can definitely go into some of the
details and the costs associated with it
is is quite expensive for the state to
do um and also with any state government
agency your adding a lot of overhead and
costs from state employees so we would
probably not urge um New Hampshire go
that route and and housing a state lab
but I think a thirdparty vendor um at
least to to check independent
Laboratories would make sense and a
state the size of New Hampshire you
probably don't need um too many
independent State Labs I I know you guys
currently have one um that has been
sufficient for overseeing the the
current program um but I I think it
would be wise to at least add an
additional lab um with the expansion
into adult recreational use um do you
have anything to add I would um I would
just like to concur what she said you
know most States we've seen with the
reference lab model Can Do Spot checks
you're seeing you know currently in
California their Department of cannabis
control has recently been stepping up
enforcement and uh recently sent letters
to um all the Laboratories saying that
they were checking their potency test
numbers to prevent against potency
inflation which has been rampant
throughout the industry but I would say
for the state you're looking you I would
say conservatively at a $5 million
appropriation to be able to outfit a lab
if you were going to do a full state run
lab with the gamut of testing that um
typically would be required for Cannabis
Testing um so with that you know it in
my opinion I think it would be more
beneficial to the state to be able to
Outsource to a third
party thank you so you referenced
Oklahoma so it sounds like what they did
was they have a license for third party
independent Labs at the manufacturers
and the cultivators could could go to
direct to get their lab reports to
submit to the state and then on top of
that they have an A the state itself
contracted with a lab which I assume is
ex can't be one of these other labs that
that are doing testing to do
specifically testing for the state to
validate the lab the third party Labs
that uh grower manufacturers are using
that's correct so they they did go that
route um and you're absolutely correct
if the if the vendor is contracted with
the state they are unable to do any
direct testing for Growers um and
producers uh that's that's a great check
uh you want to make sure that there's
not that that um uh interference
potentially between um between that spot
check but they have decided in this past
legislative session to inhouse that lab
um like I said they I think they were
probably contracted was is the wrong
vendor um I I believe I saw that it was
costing over $10 million a year to
contract with that vendor which is
actually insane um and so they were able
when they did their fiscal impact report
to say that they could bring that cost
down significantly for the state by
in-housing a lab which is true on its
surface um and and like Ron said to get
a a state-of-the-art lab up and running
to do all the tests that you need to to
have done for product safety Consumer
safety Public Safety um it it will be
about at least $5 billion appropriation
on the onset and then the ongoing cost
of of running that lab so um that's just
the route that they're going right now
they're in the process of standing that
up um I give a lot of credit to to
Oklahoma uh medical marijuana Authority
they have been uh really grappling with
a with getting some control on the
medical program that they have when they
first um open that program a few years
back they kind of just opened the doors
on it and so they've spent the last
couple of years trying to get that under
control um they do have a lot of
third-party Labs that are licensed with
the state um a good chunk of them are
not operational um are not in compliance
um and have you know various issues
Chief among them usually is uh cash flow
that ends up shutting them down so um
you know they're they're doing what they
can to kind of get their hands around
them I again I don't think that inh
housing a state lab is the best way to
to go um you know when it comes to to
state Laboratories we we know that they
usually have their hands full with
dealing with um violent crimes and and
all of the investigative work that needs
to happen there and we feel that
cannabis is is something that needs to
be outside of that um and not a
distraction because it does take up a
lot of time and
effort thank you um representative
kahill then representative o thank you
Mr chair so can you speak to like how
your third these third party Labs like
is there an accreditation program that
they're going through like who who Who's
responsible for that and you know I I um
I spent some time working in an army
research lab and we had like thorough
accreditation programs for for what we
were working on and it just like you to
speak to that yes that's a great
question um in Most states uh most
Cannabis Testing Labs if not all are ISO
17025 accredited so have to go through
that accreditation process through an
accreditation body meaning that they
have a quality management system in
place that all their Sops are defined
and they can be checked they have to
keep up with non-conformance issues uh
have quality controls through their
testing with each batch that happens
multiple quality controls for each
specific set
um is there a length of time that the
they have to store their data on um like
like five years 20 years or how long are
they required to keep their data on um
that can range um I've seen as little as
three years but up to
seven represent Val thank you Mr chair
you mentioned the figure of $5 million
and then you mentioned an ISO
requirement now the iso requirements is
from my understanding because they apply
apply only to private entities not
necessarily to State entities
is that
correct um if I'm
uh based on ISO any laboratory could
become ISO accredited so the state
laboratory if they chose could pursue
that route okay um however they yeah
follow up thank you
however having an ISO uh
certification by a state entity does not
detract from the state's entity to
present evidence today M even with the
existence of a national standard or
actually International
standard for preventing uh presenting
evidence
regarding
whatever uh in a court of law so the the
iso stand uh standing is not uh
necessarily
required where did you come up with the
$5 million cost to New Hampshire were
already doing
it the $5 million cost would be starting
a lab essentially from the ground up um
the cost of Capital Equipment uh plus
buildout and all the infrastructure and
even smaller equipment necessary to be
able to do the
testing okay we got some more on the
side so yeah I'm just the last one so
that would be to start from scratch so
that has no application since we already
have testing facility in in in New
Hampshire at the state
lab the question then would be if under
the plan that we brought
forward the state La would be testing
the testers do you have an estimate of
the
cost that would depend on the equipment
currently in place with the state lab
and the capabilities of that equipment
to be able to do the requisite tested
testing
needed and may I just provide a quick
clarification when we the the $5 million
um number that wasn't for the State of
New Hampshire that's just the experience
that we have had in building out a lab
um so I certainly don't want to to pin
that number down for you guys or have
that I just wanted to put something out
there so there's a basic understanding
of the cost of the equipment that goes
into these Labs we're currently um in
the process of building out a lab in
Moss Point uh Mississippi and you know
we we had really thought it was going to
be closer to $3 million and by the time
you get all the state-of-the-art
equipment necessary to to have full
compliance for cannabis that number does
creep up quite a bit um to to about $5
million once you get all the equipment
in place so to be clear the $5 million
assumes no lab existed so the real cost
is going to be somewhere between zero
and five million depending on what the
expansion we may have to do for the
increased testing and number of
personnel and that kind of stuff along
yeah along with Personnel yeah so all
right down here great thank you Mr chair
uh and thank you for being here with
this important uh testimony I do have a
question uh cannabis is widely
misperceived as being a harmless green
plant um aside from the from the high
potency THC and the hes associated with
that when we think about toxins and and
um pesticides and things along that line
I'm just curious it you know in
recreational um marijuana uh you know
distribution is there such a thing as
organic uh cannabis
um I I'll let Ron answer that question
because I I think some sometimes we get
really caught up in in questions about
potency and um you know whether it's
harmful or it's not um I think from what
I've read from what I've understood and
from what I've learned from Ron uh the
more harmful things are some of the
heavy metals and the pesticides that get
into the product during cultivation um
and just for the record I do want to
state that we are a Cannabis Testing
company uh but we are agnostic to
legalization and I know the charge of
this commission is is not to uh question
whether or not it should be legal but
really how do how do you move forward in
implementing a program so you know we're
not here today to advocate for the
safety um and the the um the
effectiveness of cannabis but just re
really saying if it's going to be legal
it needs to be tested it needs to be
safe for public um consumption but Ron
do you want to answer that and as far as
organic if you look at actual USDA
organic standards um one cannabis based
on definition can't be USDA organic but
if you look at the list of pesticides
that most say organic produce is tested
for and compare that to say the
pesticide testing list of a a California
or a Mississippi um a lot of that
product will actually be cleaner than
USDA organic produce um but the reason
for that is when you combust these
potential pesticides and things that
could be on this um one pesticide in
particular mic mobinil um can turn into
hydrogen cyanide um that could
potentially kill someone but with usdaa
organic produce you're ingesting so the
body can break down or it simply passes
through the system whereas if you are
combusting a product due to the
limitations of research in this country
because of the National Institutes of
drug abuse standards uh we don't know
what happens when you combust these on
cannabis material so um it's um I would
say most beneficial to have a very
stringent testing regime when it comes
to things like pesticides and heavy
metals to ensure if a consumer wants to
partake of this product that they are
partaking of a product that's clean and
as safe as possible for the research
that we currently have okay thank you so
just one question I'm not sure if you
provided this this this Canadian list of
all the chemicals and the pesticides
that are tested for in Labs under the
Canadian model is that is that an
exhaustive list um but you know is there
has this been modified so it looks like
it's a 2018 document the Canadian list
is a very extensive model and it's it's
more extensive than most of the the
actually most all of the states
currently in the US that have a
legalized model be it medical or
recreational and one one follow the the
um quantities that they're talking about
for for how much is is found in a given
product are those again are those
besides the number of products they're
number of um ingredients they're looking
for is the quantity again of these
levels normal I mean when I say normal
other states are looking at for what if
if they're listed or do you know if it's
more restringing um can I ask for
clarification is that like an action
limit set for a um I'm guessing it's a
it's a trigger marker right so yes so um
I would have to look at that document
particularly to be able to tell you each
state does treat different pesti sides
or residual solvents a bit differently
um even within this state with your
current medical program seeing the
action limits for your heavy medals um
to me is actually quite surprising
because it's quite High compared to some
of the other states that I've helped
groups set um Labs um up for other
Medical Systems
um thank you
Che yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh for your testimony so uh point of
clarification so is it fair to say that
that in your uh in your testimony that
you would recommend that a testing
regime include a third-party vendor that
would be certified by the state to
specific standards with a uh separate
verification or Reference Lab either uh
by state run or by um a vendor is would
that be
correct I think so yes okay so uh and
excuse me followup followup yes um so
would it also be fair to say then that
uh if you could say based on your
experience and knowledge in the testing
uh industry uh and in the market what is
your um opinion if you can offer one
with respect to the percentage of states
that have state operated reference
Laboratories versus states that have
legalized and use a third-party vendor
for a reference lab if you can offer an
opinion um I would have to get back to
you on that I don't know the specific
number off the top of my head of states
that employ either model follow up Mr
chair uh if you were to uh
recommend uh the difference between a
state uh operated Reference Lab versus a
third-party vendor Reference Lab um what
would you recommend based on your
experience um and knowledge in the
industry based on my experience I would
recommend a third-party lab um and I
think with a state this size um you
would be able to work more in
conjunction with having a thirdparty lab
like that um and and use their expertise
to benefit the state followup Mr chair
um are you familiar with um some
open-source testing of California um
retail cannabis that was done by various
media Outlets that discovered
significant presence of toxins
particularly heavy metals and pesticides
in the U California retail stores were
you aware of
that oh could you say when the study was
um there have been multiple um checks in
California recently
the the most recent uh data that I have
uh started uh in the early 2000s with
followup spot checks that occurred in uh
in about 2009
2011 that would be quite a quite an old
study and I would say based on my
experience from having operated a a
Cannabis Testing Lab in California that
the products that I signed off on as as
the signatory on the C ofas we had very
few heavy metal failures once the
program in California became um it
became necessary to do heavy metals
testing for um both medical and
recreational Cannabis follow up Mr
chair can you offer an opinion based on
your knowledge of the population and
projected size of the retail industry
for cannabis in New Hampshire what the
cost would be to the state to
um operate of u a well-regulated
testing uh regime for both uh industry
testing as well as reference testing if
you can offer an opinion as the
cost and that would be based on uh your
recommendation for third-party
independent not State operated
Laboratory
yeah um as far as a specific dollar
number I don't think I could give you
one but you would have the you know
ongoing cost with with staff um as well
as you know the necessary chemicals the
reagents the analytical standards um
that are necessary to be able to do all
this testing these standards um for
example for as small as a 1 mil ampule
for say a cannabinoid standard could
cost you $0000 um so when you start to
multiply that out and as frequently as
that's used um the cost depending on the
size and the frequency of runs and also
your number of employees um could start
to go up do you want to talk a little
bit about clarification Mr chair sure go
ahead follow um my my question I think
goes more toward uh based on your
opinion and uh operation of Laboratory
is that that test cannabis what
generally would be the cost to the state
uh on a contract annual basis for
example to run both a testing laboratory
contract and then a second independent
Reference Laboratory contract if you can
offer such opinion as to the cost not
state run this would be um
independent so Chief I'm I'm just going
to give a look a little bit of a
clarification just on the legislative
process part of this is going to be
based on what we decide the number of
tests that are required how many batches
how many tests it's awful hard as we
haven't gotten deep into that standard
or or even had uh liquor give us what
that standard would look like to even
guess what the price would be so just
just I'm just trying to you know they're
they're you're asking for a number based
on unknown facts that they don't have
get there that could vary greatly
depending I know in your current
regulation it says that that um test for
cannabis products are quarterly Most
states require test based on each batch
and there's a maximum batch size in
California you can have up to a 50 lb
Harvest batch of cannabis flour in
Mississippi that's 25 lbs in Nevada it's
10 pounds so depending
upon how often um as the senator said uh
would be required to test and those
batch limits and whatnot that would
affect the cost to State thank you Mr
chair I appreciate um the clarification
and that was actually what I was trying
to get to which is uh trying to have um
the folks provide us with uh perhaps
their knowledge with respect to testing
and what what that looks like and so my
question now is is it fair to say then
that there's not really no industry
standard right based on States uh in
terms of batch size which varies greatly
with respect to cost so it could vary
based on the lower batch size which
would perhaps um provide a greater uh
quality standard uh as opposed to a
larger badge size with representative
samples that would diminish the
opportunity for obtaining uh qualified
test that would detect toxins heavy
metals or pesticides would that be fair
to say yes it would be okay thank you
thank you so I want last simple question
hopefully we can get to a number the
chief might like so I think you said
Alabama was does a 25 pound batch of
flower Mississippi I'm sorry Mississippi
does a 20 pound 25 pound batch sampling
uh and testing on a given sample like
that is there an estimated cost that
would would that we would know what
would it cost uh a lab to be able to
process on 20 that 25lb batch sample to
to test for all of the heavy metals all
of the car cens all of the um mold and
all the other things what what would it
cost again the cost to the lab to
actually perform the testing um would
depend one on how much your
instrumentation cost is um and also what
specifically is required for the testing
so if you have a quite large pesticide
panel the cost would be more than say if
you had a panel similar to that from
Oklahoma which is quite limited can you
a what of a ballpark trying trying to
get to that's what I knew you were about
to get to thank Mr exactly where I was
going to give you an actual number um we
base a lot of our modeling in in the
labs and in the national average right
now for full panel testing again it's
dependent on every state because they
require different things about $450 to
the grower the producer getting the test
done by the private lab by the the
independent lab so about
$450 per sample is the cost of of
getting that tested thank you um I can
also provide if it is helpful um what
the fiscal impact report was for for
Oklahoma when they were looking at doing
the Reference Lab in housee and and for
the state if that's a helpful number
just to kind of give um a ballpark of
what it might look like for a state like
New Hampshire I'd be happy to provide
that one more question Mr chair um when
you referen the the uh Quebec uh
pesticide mandatory uh Cannabis Testing
for pesticide and and we can provide
this with you and your testimony
indicated that it was more extensive
than other states uh to your knowledge
can you offer an opinion as to why the
Canadians who probably have the most
experience with legalization of cannabis
in terms of uh a nationwide program
would have a more extensive list than
what US states have put in
place I think that is a question that
comes down to the policy makers in the
US that have DEC ided the list and and
as you can see you know a state like
California has a a um very extensive
list I think there are some 64 65
pesticides on that list um so that's one
of the closest to the Canadian list but
I I I can't say that I I don't disagree
with the Canadian list being extensive I
think the more we test the safer that we
can provide a product to uh the consumer
um so I do I think that that list is
necessarily Overkill no
um it just again it varies state byst
state based on you know agricultural
practices things like that thank
you representative or thank you Mr chair
um it was mentioned a 25 pound sample of
flour okay the several sections to this
what would be a sample size for each of
the different types of of materials that
are
available uh that's a great question we
could provide some examples of that from
other states um so as far as a
representative sample from that 25 pound
batch um normally a lab would to do a
representative sampling would take a
small percentage say anywhere from 0.25
to
0.5% of that 25 pounds into the into the
lab to do testing if it's on a finished
product based so say a an edible product
or a cartridge then you're going to have
different based on how many units are
produced you would take a certain amount
of
um uh units to be able to do the
requisite
testing follow units y units so I'm
going to ask you for a homework
assignment because I send to hand those
out regularly um would it be possible
for you to to generate for us a
contaminant list and a trigger and the
trigger level um similar to the Canadian
what what you see in other states and
what's going on and give us a reasonable
contaminant list with trigger levels and
the second thing I'm going to ask you
for is the sample size that they're
representative in a given batch what's
your recommendation for what's the bit
batch of flour batch of Edibles batch of
whatever those products right what that
what sample size would you recommend to
to do the testing from we would be happy
to do that thank
you yeah this is more of a question for
us so under our current plan that we're
we're our draft are are we responsible
for creating that list or is this
something that would fall under under
liquor I guess my reason for asking is
either or right so if it ends up
something we want to put in the statute
for all the contaminate list and we can
do that it makes it harder for the
director to modify that later on or it
may just be a sample of we've got it we
can hand it over to them and they can
write their rules and regulations based
on that but it'd be nice to have the
information for the
discussion
anything else thank you guys very much
appreciate it thank
you next up we have Lynn Sila from
getting it right from the
start thank you chairman Lang members of
the commission it's an honor to be here
with you this morning um I was asked to
prepare a slightly longer presentation
if that's okay okay
um my name is Dr Lynn silver I'm a
pediatrician uh senior adviser at the
Public Health Institute and um full
professor at the University of
California San Francisco for better for
worse I've got about four Decades of
experience in public health policy often
uh working on issues of regulation of
legal but harmful substances uh since
shortly before the passage of
proposition 64 which legalized
recreational cannabis use in California
I founded an oversee uh getting it right
from the start initiative our Focus has
been to work where cannabis has been or
is being legalized uh to identify
potential best practices to protect
children Public Health and Social Equity
uh we carry out extensive research
supported by NIH and other funders to
assess cannabis policy impact on health
to develop tools and model laws um for
local government and Community Partners
um and with Foundation support we Prov
provided technical assistance to
Partners in over 100 California cities
and counties 15 states and some other
countries um for the 27 US states which
have not yet legalized recreational
Cannabis we believe that there is an
opportunity to learn and greatly improve
what is being done by States if they do
uh decide to move forward the governor's
office invited me to come uh to New
Hampshire and share some of our findings
and Lessons Learned to help inform your
challenging decision- making the sort of
top 10 um first let me say that I am not
here to tell you whether to legalize or
not uh there are very good arguments to
be made for and against I'm here to
share with you ways that if you do
decide to move forward you can reduce
harms from legalization and better
protect children uh first I'll try and
share just a few facts on the health
impacts of non-medical Canabis use what
Healthcare Providers are seeing and then
talk about some key strategies to reduce
these arms if you choose to move
forward um I've shared some materials
summarizing key points and some slides
and pictures of products from California
but I won't be reading through them um I
come at this problem as a pediatrician
public health professional who spend her
life trying to find ways to prevent
illness before it happens and someone
who's been studying the Cannabis
industry for the past seven years but I
also come to it as a mother and stepmom
of five um and lastly someone who uh
love somebody who developed psychosis
and schizophrenia um so preventing every
case of serious mental illness is some
that is preventable not all of them are
um but some are is very personal uh to
me um so let's talk briefly about health
effects the product New Hampshire is
deciding how to treat is not the
Botanical plant um from the days of my
college days or or most of yours um that
joint your mama may have rolled had
about 3 to 5%
uh THC in it it got you high but only
rarely did it make people seriously ill
over the last 20 years the United States
cannabis Market has become something
completely different uh changes in
agriculture and um and and growing um
procedures um have led to flour that is
5 to 10 times stronger currently at
about 20 to 35% THC and a vast array of
manufactured aggressively marketed
flashily packaged inhal able
concentrates and Edibles as well as
so-called but still intoxicating hemp
products has emerged many are 80 90 to
100% THC including these hemp products
um some imitate McFlurries Cocoa Pebbles
nachos or Skittles uh as you can see in
the pictures of some legal California
products that I included in in your
package that we've been trying
unsuccessfully frankly to get off the
market in
California um my colleague Professor
Carini and in Washington notes that
today's products are to Botanical
cannabis with strawberry Pop-Tarts are
to strawberries or I would say what
Coca-Cola is to a beet plant I call it
the coca-c isation of cannabis um we are
um a country that is very good at and
Incredibly creative at marketing things
and that can be a really good thing in
some sectors um but in this particular
case it is not necessarily the case so
why most people can still get high at a
party without ill effects and many enjoy
that a growing minority of consumers do
not get off so easy between one and two
out of every 10 users are developing
dependency that's more frequent the
younger they start vaping cannabis by
12th graders has tripled nationally
since 2017 often occurring before or at
school disrupting education many schools
are not letting kids go to the bathroom
during class uh because they're seeing
so much vaping in the bathroom daily use
in young adults nationally has tripled
um and that means that today
approximately one in0 American 19 to 30y
olds is walking around High almost every
day um and a whole lot of high school
students so those are not good
statistics for learning or for
productivity ask any school principal
what they are
seeing uh daily use of cannabis above
10% THC which is pretty much the entire
US market um is associated with a three
to fivefold increase in the risk of
psychosis a problem that we all know
that as a society we are facing great
challenges managing and one that is
filling our streets with people with
poorly controlled serious mental illness
the current estimates are that perhaps
12 to 15% of nuon said psychosis cases
may be uh cannabis triggered
particularly with the frequent use of
high potency products uh like Vapes dabs
waxes and shatters resin um the numbers
vary a bit by study but they are not
smaller in significant here's what one
PR pediatric provider said in our latest
research study I can think of three or
four kids off the top of my head in the
last five months who were actually
psychotic I was trying to talk to them
and they were yeah they were psychotic
drug induced psychosis that we didn't
used to see so much um sometimes this
can be reversed if the person or their
doctor understands what's going on in
some children or young or typically
young adults these can be irreversible
breaks initiating long-term um
schizophrenia we know now that uh
cannabis use is also associated with
increases in suicidality mood disorders
car accidents and probably heart attacks
even though many consumers use it
believing Mis misleading industry
messaging that it is a safe stress
relever um poisonings of young children
are up, 1400% nationally cannabis ER
visits in California by seniors Rose by8
00% in a decade um cannabis use
interferes with adolescent cognition and
the likelihood of graduating high
school
um so as a pediatrician of great concern
to me and this is wrapping up health
effects is used during pregnancy where
it is not only associated with low birth
weight and prematurity but also with
long-term neurological harms and
psychopathology and children exposed in
utero according to the recent uh major
NIH study which is looking at how teen
cognition is developing in the United
States and what's affecting it so we're
seeing something similar to fetal
alcohol syndrome in some children who
are exposed in utera um these are bells
that an exposed child cannot unring and
which may affect the course of their
life and yet cannabis use in pregnancy
has nearly doubled in California and
risen nationally exposing the next
generation of children to more harm
these are Health harms not from an
occasional study but as concluded by the
nationaly of science they're summarized
in page two of your packet um for these
reasons I was very pleased to hear
governor cuno and this body have been
examining a Fresh Approach of a state
controlled cannabis system with the goal
of reaping some of the benefits of
legalization and less of the harms a
smarter approach let's examine what some
of the pillars of such a system might
look like what are the guard rails as
somebody mentioned that needs to be put
in that need to be put in place place
and cannot be left for last as some
states have done first on criminal
justice uh I believe that one of the
strongest Arguments for decriminalizing
has been the long standing history of
discriminatory arrests and incarceration
and we need to address these I know the
state has taken some important steps um
according to the ACLU in 2018 blacks in
New Hampshire were still four-fold more
likely to have a marijuana possession
arrest although I've been told that
arrests are now weighed down um this
needs to be fixed but you don't need to
create a giant for-profit industry to
fix this um by decriminalizing
smallscale possession further um and
creating and funding the process for
automatic expungement of criminal
records associated with non-violent
cannabis possession much of that past
and future inequity can be relieved uh
California has now expunged 93% of
eligible convictions with huge benefit
for over 200,000 people that is very
feasible you can do that today no matter
where you go with legalization so that
people who got caught with a joint in
the past can get scholarships and
housing and face fewer obstacles in life
we also recommend that penalties for
miners um include community service or
Noni non- fine options to avoid civil
debt trap from fines for miners um who
may be caught with uh with cannabis
possession but in our understanding the
real future danger to the health of New
Hampshire residents comes not from a few
plants or even from pesticide residues
it comes from what happens when you
build a Powerhouse of agricultural
industrial and Retail interests that
profit from a harmful and addictive drug
in short from building a new tobacco
industry my parents were small business
people and I grew up helping in the
family store um but cannabis is not
clothes or potatoes cannabis is no
ordinary commodity like tobacco you
don't want it or hemp to be the growth
engine of the New Hampshire economy you
may choose to allow it but more is not
better because whatever revenue or jobs
it generates will be heavily offset by
health care and social expenditures by
more people with expensive and
devastating mental illness some of who
end up in jail premature babies young
children with uh problems more car
accidents the burden of these harms will
not be equitably
distributed
um I did some calculations on psychosis
I can share them with you later but my
general point is don't get star eyed
with Revenue projections from private
operators or franchises if you do this
wrong and create an industry that drives
up consumption and the more serious
adverse effects you'll essentially be
robbing Peter to pay Paul um for every
dollar in taxes you'll spend one or two
on psychiatric beds or rehab units so
that leads me to the fundamental
conclusion either Don't Legalize
commercial sales and live with the
ambiguity of decriminalization uh as the
Dutch and the Portuguese do um which can
be okay or legalize with a very
different approach one that says we will
allow legal sale but only in a very
careful system whose specified goal is
to provide legal access more safely but
without driving up consumption one that
expressly seeks to avoid a new big
tobacco the data suggest to me that one
of the best examples of safer
legalization of cannabis is in Quebec
your neighbor to the north which
piggybacked on its existing public
alcohol system to create an exclusive
provincially owned and operated cannabis
retail system it operates attractive
stores and provides online access and
collects Revenue significant Revenue but
it doesn't aggressively advertise uh
cannabis except how people can get it
legally and wear and it strongly limits
the types of products sold to avoid the
more dangerous H High potency
concentrates flavored Vapes like Jewel
which are widely sold in California for
cannabis and products that are obviously
going to attract children Quebec has had
the same high transition to the legal
Market as other provinces uh but less
growth in population consumption levels
and high public satisfaction they've
generated profitable margins that go to
the state fund and use of the more
dangerous High potency products are low
relative to other provinces most
fascinating is that according to
marijuana Business Daily recently uh
they are the most economically
successful cannabis businesses in Canada
so the publicly operated ones in Canada
are actually doing better than most of
the private sector uh some of this data
is in your packets so can we do this in
the United States um in the US where
cannabis remains federally illegal there
are concerns and legitimate concerns
about public employees and I imagine the
Liquor Commission is worried about this
uh there were concerns about public
employees running running a business
that's still federally illegal um the
public health law Center in Minnesota
studied this issue and identified some
potential workarounds um one is
specifically to use an exclusive state
license or Contracting process with a
nonprofit to manage the system so you're
kind of creating a a distance uh of the
state from the process why still
exercising uh considerable control
similar to the way that we might um
issue a permit to an exclusive Regional
electric provider um only with a
nonprofit um in this way you can write
strong terms to protect Youth and reduce
harms both in law and in the permitting
or contractual process you can more
broadly restrict marketing than you can
in law because of First Amendment
concerns profits from this system can be
channeled back to support substance use
prevention Youth and Community reinvest
and Community reinvestment hiring can be
Equity focused um The Liquor Commission
could for example incubate and create a
nonprofit and share its board which is
an approach we took when I was in New
York government to create a nonprofit
for medication access um or could use an
existing nonprofit I don't know New
Hampshire well enough to um say how you
should do that um I believe however in
contrast that the proposed franchise
system like McDonald's and other
franchise uh franchises would still be
run by franchisees whose logical and
natural Mission would be to maximize
their sales and
profitability um and that that should
not be the mission of a legal cannabis
system so I recommend that you seek a
state um organized not for-profit
approach um through exclusive permit or
other mechanisms rather than um
franchising for-profit
organizations another um aspect to look
at is retail density uh in our research
we've studied uh pregnant use by
pregnant women and by teens and we find
it directly proportional to how many
retailers there are within a 15minute
drive from uh the person's house uh you
have it pretty close to write on public
alcohol Stores um in the state if it's
enough to provide whiskey it's enough to
provide weed you may need less um but
you certainly don't need more Stores um
we generally recommend not having more
than one per 20,000 inhabitants or so um
it takes a while to get there it's okay
keep them far away from schools and
colleges and also from residential areas
I recommend you don't promise to open
them all overnight because so many
states have gotten into trouble with
Promises of excessive speed and that was
not
feasible conflicts of interests
conflicts of interests should be
strongly prohibited this is one of the
worst characteristics of what's happened
around the country we would not let the
tobacco industry write the regulations
for tobacco and we should not be letting
the Cannabis industry write the
regulations for cannabis you want to
have some organization that melds
management proficiency with public
health and substance abuse expertise not
one that views its Mission as promoting
and growing the Cannabis industry as
quickly as possible you should have an
oversight body that approves regulations
that's composed of scientists doctors
Educators law enforcement and economists
but with no direct Financial interest in
the industry no one in the regulatory
system should have
conflicts that's not to say that the
industry does not have indispensable and
Essential Knowledge to contribute to how
you write regulations they should have a
voice and there should be a robust
mechanism for public input um but they
should not be controlling the
process once you get started there's a
number of other areas to think about the
first is products what products should
be sold in reality the health harms of
cannabis are determined far more by what
is intentionally put in the product than
by accidental contaminants or residues
so why lab testing is important the type
defining the type of allowable products
is actually far more
important um the regulatory body should
focus uh from the start on only allowing
a restricted and lower risk and lower
potency range of products we do not need
99% THC shatter for dabbing or wax pens
States like Connecticut and New Jersey
as well as Quebec and ugay have all
imposed potency caps other states New
York and Illinois for example tax by THC
content to discourage the higher THC uh
products you can also do that through
pricing if you start very cautiously you
can always decide to loosen up over time
what is exceedingly difficult to do is
if you allow a product to then come back
and pull it off the market that becomes
almost in part uh
impossible I would say if you're going
to invest thinking of the the previous
uh testimony if you're going to invest
State money invested in enforcement in
creating a a cautious system um and then
regulating products very carefully and
that will bring more public health and
safety return than building uh your own
lab for example which can be a very high
capital
investment um start with lower potency
flow and Ables and either don't allow
concentrates for the first 3 years or
cap the THC content for example at
40% um have the oversight commission
specifically evaluate what happens the
industry is going to say oh you're just
going to push people to the illicit
market for these products um but in
Quebec that wasn't what happened um if
as in Quebec it keeps overall use of
high potency products down then may be a
good decision if it doesn't then you
might need to adjust but just calling
that with the exception of hash and some
other traditional concentrates most of
these turbocharged products uh didn't
even exist uh very long a few few years
back um if you know High potency product
use is rising then you can re-evaluate
also I would note that the allowable
amounts for a person to hold and
allowable doses should be much lower
than what are in in the draft they're
much higher than in other states I have
never seen a 20 mgram as the standard
serving dose anywhere the ni and others
recommend 5 Mig California uses 10 Mig
uh 20 milligrams will get an
inexperienced user to stoned um and
guidelines recommend that people start
with just a couple of milligrams Most
states allow and Canada allow 1 ounce um
although some have larger um home
amounts I want to talk for a minute
about hemp um because these are the same
plant and we can't pretend that they're
not um regulation should I ideally be
integrated with hemp regulation to
ensure that intoxicating hemp products
are not being sold period the 0.3% THC
by weight criteria never worked for
Edibles which I understand are not
allowed in in New Hampshire if that's
correct um but it's also not working
very well for inhaled products um this
is um can I ask you pass something
around these are products
uh here go can pass this
thanks um these are products I picked up
last night in two Dairy smoke shops um
and these are highly intoxicating hemp
products that are mostly about
89% um intoxicating THC they include
three to four U some of them have ones
Delta eight some of them have as many as
three artificial cannabinoids like I
call them Franks they're they're a
product of the farm bill um and the
loopholes in the farm bill that have led
companies to take excess CBD chemically
modify it into uh versions new isomers
of THC which I believe you tried to
address a few months ago in law um
there's about 20 25 of them now one of
them thcp is about more than 30 times as
potent as traditional Delta 9
THC um there's absolutely no data on
safety on these uh so I would recommend
um first you that you make some
improvements and strengthen your law by
clearly uh prohibiting the whole list of
these artificial cannabinoids both for
the hemp sector and the Cannabis sector
because these substances are starting to
make their way into cannabis sales as
well and that in addition to the 0.3
criteria that's in your current law that
you impose a simple per package limit of
no more than 1 milligram of any of these
intoxicating canab oid uh that may be
easier to enforce right now you'd
practically have to be a chemist to go
enforce in some of these places I mean I
know how to read these but took I'd
never heard of half this stuff not too
long ago and some of it didn't exist
five years ago um so you need simple
clear enforceable rules and you need
actual investment and enforcement if you
don't constrain what's going on on the
hemp side you will completely undermine
a more robust uh state-led cannabis
system because this is cannabis it's
highly intoxicating cannabis it has the
same negative health effects and if you
can go into any smoke shop and buy it it
doesn't help to create a well-controlled
uh cannabis system uh packaging
packaging really matters as you can see
from the pictures in your packeting in
your package um that's a lot of what
makes products attract kids um and that
needs to be addressed by clearly uh
managing packaging you can reduce reduce
a lot of the burden of uh verifying
whether a product is attractive to kids
Maryland used to approve each package
but that's a lot of work we strongly
recommend um that you define
attractiveness to children in law and
detail and I can provide some draft
language I saw there was some already in
there I detail it further um but I would
also require plain packaging which four
US states have already done and Canada
has done and which is the international
standard for tobacco so make the
packages simple one color no pictures of
cartoons or animals or you know apples
and oranges and cherries and so forth um
because those things um create the
illusion that the product is healthier
than it is and there's very good
evidence to substantiate that so we
recommend plain packaging as used in
Connecticut New Jersey Missouri and
someplace else um Health warnings um
current health warnings in Most states
are extremely weak they're in Sixpoint
font they're so small that nobody can
read them um I in there's one slide in
your uh packet uh that gives some
examples of how hard they are to see uh
we recommend based on um extensive
research both from tobacco and cannabis
following the model that the FDA is
adopting for cigarettes which is front
of pack prominent pictorial rotating
Health warnings so you take a single
Health statement at a time you put it on
the package and you rotate across
warnings um because people can focus on
a single statement about pregnancy or
about U mental health or other things
but not on 10 different ones very well
um and that be prominently placed and
ideally accompanied by a picture um this
is very important because what we're
seeing is
uh basically declining perception of
harm from Cannabis in the population
even as the products have actually
gotten U more harmful less harmful from
a contaminant standpoint but more
harmful from an intentional uh design
and potency standpoint
um and we really need to correct and
educate the public using front of pack
warnings delivers uh education on what
the risks are directly to the people who
are consuming and at no cost to
government um so it's very valuable
advertising uh we believe that
advertising should be restricted to the
extent possible under law so that
children are not exposed that Billboards
not be allowed Um this can actually is
something else that can work much better
under an exclusive um government
controlled system
um we don't think you know they should
be selling cookies sweatshirts cookies
is a major brand of of cannabis um for
kids to be using at school loow control
should be
preserved um that may mean that things
go a little bit slower that your
legalization process is not uniform
that's something that's been happening
in California and legalization has been
gradually increasing every year across
the state uh 63% of Californians now
live in legal cities or counties
probably closer to 80 or 90% of them
live nearby where they can cross a small
border and have access um taxes whether
the state adopts a public or nonprofit
uh system taxes or margins captured in
other ways should probably be 20 to 40%
and ideally tiered to THC content 15% I
believe is too low to fund everything
you want to fund and lower than many
other states Washington for example is
37% if it is a state run process this
could alternatively be captured through
uh setting prices and recapturing
margins there's a couple ways to do it
um contrary to what industry says low
taxes have not solved the illicit Market
uh not allowing overproduction of the
proc of the product may be more
successful at constraining a lcit market
too much weed looking for a warm body to
consume it is the unhappy formula that
is driving massive elicit markets from
California to Oklahoma don't copy us um
unlimited cultivation is creating a glut
of product which has led to Falling
prices failing businesses persist in
illicit sales and aggressive Marketing
in many states so we recommend that
cultivation licenses and production
amounts be limited uh to try and
basically Target uh what you think
you'll be able to sell through the
system that's created um or and
certainly not exceed current Exum
consumption um if for-profit retailers
are allowed which I don't recommend I
would recommend that most initial
licenses be reserved for Equity
applicants not just a couple extra
points in the formula um and they will
need time uh to get started and to be
successful if they're competing against
Rich investors from the start uh
typically they fail so in California
only about 10% of current storefronts
are owned by Equity
licenses um so uh finishing up as we
speak the cannabis industry labists are
likely inundating the halls of this
General Court this is happening across
the country federally in every state
making campaign donations just as the
tobacco industry did um I encourage
political leaders such as yourself to go
talk to school principls teachers nurses
psychiatrists rehab centers and parents
and ask what they are seeing go visit
your neighborhood vape store and see
what's for sale the situation is not
good I believe you can build something
wise and solid for the Long Haul um or
you can copy systems that are proving
pretty disastrous um we are still
learning but please learn from our
mistakes be cautious be deliberate take
the profit out of it if you choose to
legalize commercial activity flip the
script and base everything on creating
legal access through a system that does
not drive up consumption and that can
protect our children um I appreciate the
opportunity to be here with you today
and to share what we've learned so far
um I thank the governor's office and the
members of this committee and I'm happy
to serve as a resource as a resource as
you navigate these challenging choices
thank
you thanks doctor could you get a copy
of your written statement to Ryan's not
here when we give it to daily so that we
can make sure it's entered into the
record cleanly okay thank you can I
clean it up and email it to you or
should I sure clean it up in
email Mr chair is it is is it possible
for every committ Committee Member to
get a copy sure one once we get a
digital copy cleaned up version we'll
make sure everybody gets a copy of it
and it'll be included in the report at
the end of the thank you okay if someone
can provide me the email to so questions
for the
doctor
Chief and how thank you very much I I
have more of a comment than a question I
just really want to thank you for being
here today and bringing before us a
cohesive wellth thought out plan in
order for our state to move forward
should we decide to move forward with
this a lot of what you brought before us
uh goes along with what we as the state
want to do and it's great to hear that
those are the things that we should be
doing so I just wanted to thank you
thank you
sir Chief thank you Mr chair and thank
you for your uh extraordinary testimony
today uh is very uh incisive and um
uh it points a a way and a pathway um
toward um a process that that could be
uh done um to mitigate as you say the
harmful effects if I could ask you this
question and it may be difficult for you
to answer uh but amongst all the
testimony that you provided today there
seems to be a number of areas or
elements where states have gone wrong um
pitfalls if you will things that other
states did uh that um you
recommend uh in your testimony and there
are many points but what are the most
important elements in in your view to
avoid um um creating a problem that will
be uh impossible to be able to put back
in um in
control uh thank you Mr
sir uh there are several I think the
inexurable trend that we've seen towards
increasing potency in the marketplace
with starts in agriculture and the
agricultural techniques that are
currently being used up into
manufacturing processes is probably the
biggest mistake because we've basically
allowed the product to get much more
harmful um
and um I think we have to serious ly
start looking at how do we reverse that
if we're going to sell flour how do we
have that flower be less potent not more
I saw you already had a provision to
assure that lower potency products are
at least offered in the draft which is
very important um where did set the
limits is really hard question so we
interviewed you know 100 people all
across the country experts from a wide
range of area including industry
consensus that potency is a problem
problem and one of the biggest public
health challenges when you ask what to
do about it people are all over the
place um with different solutions um and
yet that's leading to analysis paralysis
um and I would say the biggest mistake
is not to do anything about it which is
what happened in California and I think
has been a very severe mistake um so I
would say set limits start
conservatively um you can always go up
you won't be able to go down very easily
um so product regulation um not
incorporating lessons from Tobacco
Control um in a number of areas we know
whether it's packaging or Price setting
um and so
on
um
over it's a complicated issue but
allowing agricultural overproduction
which has led to a glot in many states
um I think you probably read the
newspaper article on
Oklahoma uh for example um you know and
that just creates huge pressure from
failing businesses and people who've
invested and don't have anywhere to sell
their their production um that's a big
mess we're seeing it in New York right
now we're you know we've just seen it
repeated in multiple States I I don't
know in New Hampshire how much of an
illicit production Market you have
already or not um but avoiding creating
huge new over production um this a big
big mistake is is one mistake I say look
very carefully at how you avoid that um
creating too many retail
outlets and having those retail outlets
be right next door to the University of
California Berkeley for example where I
live um where there's like 10 stores on
the street right next to the university
half of whose students are under
21 um but the more just having too many
stores so you want to have enough stores
that you can supply people legally like
your ABC Stores is that what they're
called here
the outlets um this the the state
Outlets um but not so many that you're
that they're aggressively competing to
to try and survive economically um
because the more storage there are the
harder it is um for them to capture
Market um I think you know those are and
and then not enforcing uh against
intoxicating hemp which is essentially
cannabis being sold outside of a
regulated cannabis system
one followup question Mr follow up yes
um in your testimony you you recommended
that there be a um and I apologize if I
use the wrong terminology but um a
cannabis Control Commission um and it
appears that you're familiar with uh the
proposed franchisee system here with the
Liquor Commission of New Hampshire uh
being in in charge would would that mean
that there would be an oversight Control
Commission um that would oversee and
approve what the Liquor Commission
promotes and reg for for regulation for
example I would uh recommend an
oversight commission with
um Physicians substance abuse experts um
maybe somebody from uh people from law
enforcement perhaps from Agriculture and
economics
um couple of Educators um but not
um but not um people with a direct
financial interest in the industry and
that they should review and approve um
the decisions the regulatory uh
framework what we're seeing in Most
states is advisory bodies that are
loaded down with people from
industry um and the decisions that are
taken reflect that um and again I don't
want to underestimate the expert and the
knowledge that people in the industry
have I've learned a lot from them and
and um it is essential to guiding the
process so you have to be able to hear
people from industry and get their input
um but they should not be taking the
final decisions but I do believe it also
should uh that that oversight commission
should have some power um to make sure
that those Public Health um interests
and the kids come first and not 10th uh
and that maximizing um even r to
government I think this can be a
substantial source of Revenue to
government but that maximizing that
shouldn't be driving the decision making
on the
regulations um we shouldn't be selling
products that are going to adct 30%
instead of 20% of users because it'll
bring in more money we don't want that
situation thank you so much thank you Mr
chair not that anyone does that
consciously I'm sorry representative
kale thank you Mr chair first I want to
Echo the sentiments of chairman mikica
thank you so much for your testimony was
it was phenomenal testimony and thank
you for coming out to the Grand estate
and uh talking to us so you you handed
out some products that you um picked up
at some stores in Dairy and I wrote down
a couple of notes I'm not really an
expert on on this stuff um it it looked
like there was some Delta 9 THC and some
Delta 8 in in in the packages so could
you explain what the difference with
those are um and and maybe talk a little
bit are these those uh Frankenstein oids
that you were talking
about sure um first of all it's a
pleasure to come to New Hampshire
there's much couldn't couldn't ask for a
more beautiful place to come
um the um so if you take traditional
cannabis the main and the two big
cannabinoids that are in there are CBD
canab canab oil which is not
intoxicating and Delta 9 THC which is
the psychoactive intoxicating element
that's naturally present there's more
than a hundred different cannabinoids in
there but those are the two big
um as a result of the farm bill which
said specifically in 2018 that something
was hemp if it had less than 0.3% of
Delta 9 THC uh in the
plant um chemist got very creative and
they started taking the CBD which is
dominant in hemp so hemp has more CBD
and less um less uh Delta 9
THC modifying it chemically uh because
it is related chemically to to Delta 9
to the psychoactive uh product um into a
host of there's about 2025 of them and I
can provide a list because we have a
model law on this um that get you high
um some of them like thcp are about 30
times as potent as Delta 9 so it's
extremely hazardous substance one of the
products I passed around has thcp in it
um as well as two others um there's
Delta 8 is uh one that's actually exists
in nature in very small amounts but the
industry is taking CBD and synthesizing
it the industry actually also takes CBD
and synthesize Delta 9 so some of them
may be labeled as Delta 9 that could
come naturally for the plant or
sometimes it's actually a product of of
synthesis and then there's Delta 10 hhc
Z hhco thco they're different uh
chemical reactions uh to produce these
intoxicating um new forms of products
but they're basically all farm bill
workarounds we are trying to get the
farm bill corrected but I don't know
what's going to happen with that this
year uh many of us presented testimony
to Congress on this issue um but
presuming it doesn't get solved I would
recommend that New Hampshire solve it um
these substances have basically no
safety data you know so to sell a drug
you know through the FDA you have to go
through all kinds of Trials and prove
that it's not doesn't cause cancer that
it doesn't do other things to your
health none of this stuff has been done
for these new um cannabinoids Regular
cannabis it hasn't all been done either
but we've been using it for so long we
kind of know what most of the health
effects are we're still learning some
but there's much more information um so
there's just simply no reason to allow
adding these new chemical soups out
there um and that's what Delta 8 and
Delta 10 and all these other ones are
those products though are very uh
psychoactive products the ones I passed
around they're all about 90% um
psychoactive uh iceers of THC um so
they're the idea that the hemp industry
is selling
CBD uh they are selling CBD too but a
lot of what they're making their money
off of is highly psychoactive
intoxicating hemp products and those
just shouldn't be allowed thank you so
much thank you um just for the members
we did pass a bill last year uh list
summer uh Senate
Bill 180 if you want to look at the hemp
limitations we did put into law um and
I'm pretty sure this one violates it um
right here this this would to be a
misdemeanor right now yeah the ones I
passed around I think are all illegal in
New Hampshire well so I'm not sure of
the other ones because it's it's unclear
on limitations but this one this one
specifically says it's got a total of
33.2 n% of cannabinoids um and
limitation is
0.03% um based on that s sp180 so this
one is as far as I know Chief you
probably should take possession of it
before we leave here today um but um
this one is illegal as far as I can tell
so as again synthesize THC
thco which is a a canabo acetate
limitation that is beyond what I can
read in the bill or at least my
assumption what's in the bill or or my
reading of the bill that that is so I do
think that we do have an issue I was
some of you follow me on Facebook I was
at the Pumpkin Fest this weekend um up
in lonia and this sign that said 420
Edibles and legal
THC was sitting in front of one of the
vendor booths for everybody to kids
walking by and everything else going by
and so I I will um share that because I
posted this someone from Canabis
industry contacted the the person who
was doing this because the name of the
company companies on it and they agreed
to withdraw their sign in all future
vendor applications so there is some
compliance that they're willing to do
but there's also the fact that there's
no regulatory requirement this is
completely legal because of the Delta 8
Delta 9 3% right um limitation so um
it's just an interesting the hemp Market
is an interesting little place that that
the CBD market for regulatory uh
concerns but um I did just want to
clarify one thing we're talking about
possession limits and limits for things
in in in the bill um I think you were
referencing the 20 milligrams and the
2000 um milligram THC content I think
the purpose of that wasn't in a single
product it was the concept of if you're
going to a store and buying it's like
buying a six-pack of beer versus just
buying one beer and going home and
drinking it and going back to buy
another one I think the idea was to
allow for transportation of the product
once you go to a store and buy and be
able to get it home without having you
know um a small quantity for for
possession so it's just understand that
I'm pretty sure that's what the intent
of the bill was in here that where we
talk about possession limits was how do
we deal with somebody who's not just
going to buy one you know enough to do
it right now but to take it home and and
and survive a week or or use it for a
week or two before having to go back to
the store again so yeah Ju Just to be
clear the announce is quite a bit limits
but possession limits yeah an ounce is
quite a bit so Most states have gone
with an ounce um and and um couple some
some some have gone with more um but uh
4 oz the amount that was in there was
quite on the high side and um the 20
milligrams was referring to serving
believe to standard serving dose um and
that was what I was saying was was way
um way excessive um at least twice
what's typically used more like four
times what's recommended oh we got it I
think the concept was more of buying I'm
going to the store I'm going to buy what
I might use in a week and not
necessarily what I'm going to carry on
my possession on a on a single edible or
a single that it was it was about to be
able to transport from the store back
home you know for and not get caught
with a a what would be classified as a
possession with intent to sell amount um
above above uh the legal limit so but
also as you astutely pointed out some of
this is is an Enforcement issue so some
of it's making the law maybe easier to
apply but some of it's is investing
comments right on the
mark thank you Mr chair um Dr Silva your
your testimony is one of the most
powerful arguments against legalization
that I have ever heard um we did hear
although I respect your opinion your
your position of taking no no position
on this um we did hear uh last week uh
from um two medical experts uh from from
Boston uh a child a child psychiatrist
uh from Boston Children's and a
neuroscientist and um what they did is
they provided the commission a statement
of concern of of marijuana policy in
Massachusetts and it was signed by
43 um pediatricians mental health and
addiction clinicians and scientists uh
from Massachusetts and um they spoke um
very clearly about some of the situ
situations this seeing with their
patients and they're not good uh they've
seen
um the um increased risk of serious
mental illness that that you spoke to
psychosis
schizophrenia and not only the the youth
population but the young adult
population and um they they're very
concerned about this and so they they
wanted to take a collective stance uh in
the state um I am really concerned about
these impacts as well uh potential
impacts that that most likely we we will
see in New Hampshire if many of the
safeguards that you haven't haven't
you've uh spoken to today which unlikely
to be uh to be honest to be integrated
in in our system um but I appreciate
your expertise on that uh my question
for you is um there is this widespread
um lack of public Awareness on
particularly not only the addiction
risks but the the mental health risks do
you have any advice on how we can raise
perception of risk uh amongst
particularly the parent uh population in
New
Hampshire um I think there are a number
of practical ways to raise perception of
risk I you know I used to be assistant
Health commissioner in New York we spent
a lot of money um doing education
campaigns um you know we've got grants
from federal government we use City
money to um educate people about um
tobacco about sugar sweeten beverages
about exercise um but it's
expensive um so I do recommend and and
when we started our first round of
interviews in 2017 I called the folks in
Oregon and I said what would you have
done differently he said the first thing
I would have done was I would have had
some money upfront before the stuff hit
the hit the streets doing public
education about harms um and it has to
be well done like creative stuff not
boring um you got to like get a good Ad
Agency figure out how to get people to
actually pay attention to it um so I do
think that's important that you put some
resources towards a good quality
creative public education on um on the
mental health issues on pregnancy use
it's very important um but I would ALS
also
um say that strong Health warnings on
both hemp and cannabis products um like
ones that people will actually read and
see are something that won't cost you
any money um that you know will be used
day in and day out and hit your target
audience of consumers so I would say
that's a really important place to
invest front of pack prominent victorial
Health warnings on products and and on
any
advertising uh that is allowed um there
are states that require warnings on
Advertising I forget which ones um so
it's not without precedent um and yeah
this is really hard um I was always an
advocate for legalization in the past I
was terrified I've been terrified by
what I've seen um in California and the
direction that it's taken um so I'm much
more cautious now um
and at the same time these products are
out there you know people are getting
them um they are being exposed so the
the benefit from legalization is if you
can really do this better than what the
illicit Market is is pushing on people
right now um which I would like to think
is possible we actually really really
need a state to provide a good model for
the nation of how this problem can be
addressed that's why I was so happy to
come here today um because we
desperately need that the models that
are being created are not good you know
so let New Hampshire be the place that
does it right um and creat something
that's safer um if possible if you if
you choose to legalize um that would
that would be my my request we need a
better way to do this thank you could I
follow up Dave second let me go to Dave
over
there could you tell us uh based on your
experience and looking at different
states in well Quebec in particular
typically where do the funds that the
state the revenues that the state uh
raised through the sale where do they go
to could you just start with Quebec
first um Quebec it goes to a fund um a
public fund a fair amount of which is
going to eliminate the illicit market
and to enforcement and then I believe
also to substance abuse I'd have to
double check on that um I sent I think I
sent the data to your office from the
their annual call
with with the doctor U not with Fran G
yeah Professor G from The Institute and
in Montreal um the um in other states
it's really very varied uh California
actually that's one of the things it
didn't do badly um so the tax revenue
which was $817 Million last year in a
state of 40 million people of course um
went um a smaller pot goes to community
reinvestment and economic development uh
the largest PO is the youth prevention
education and treatment fund um which um
75% of which is going to child care
slots about uh a quarter of it is going
to a youth um prevention programs which
both include like mentoring natural
resources opportunities for Youth and
Substance Abuse Prevention uh activities
um some of it goes to the Department of
Corrections for diversion programs and
other uh youth programs that are
operated through um Corrections in law
enforcement um and then off the top is
everything um that goes to the
Regulatory and enfor system so that
comes off first and then the remaining
and then there's 10 million a year for
research um so the remaining allocations
come after the basic regulatory uh
expenses are
addressed but it does vary from state to
state and with with some states has
there been an issue I know you addressed
it a little bit has there been an issue
where they become somewhat dependent on
the revenue in and for different things
and then when the there's been a revenue
drop across the country put put in
different states you know where I've
seen that is in tobacco taxes so I'm you
know tobacco taxes are very important
they've been extremely effective at
constraining use of tobacco and reducing
youth use um but they're falling because
it's working you know so we're doing a
great job consumption is declining um
but that means there's less tax revenue
so for example in California our uh
first five system which supports
children's programs is uh funded by the
tobacco tax um that taxes declining and
the system is squeezed um so that is a
problem when you fund good things um
with tax revenues on a product whose
consumption you're trying to bring down
when you succeed which you hope you do
um whatever your funding can be put in
Jeopardy so if you fund a you know
retirement system or um something um
that's not that has no flexibility um
although I think children's stuff
shouldn't have flexibility either
um you you will eventually if you're
successful at constraining consumption
you will either have to raise the tax
which is a good option so like figure 20
years from now the illicit markets gone
you're mostly in a legal Market
situation it's a product whose
consumption you want to drive down it
might be okay to raise the tax uh to
further reduce consumption um and keep
revenue stable um right now when you're
still in this elicit elicit Market
situation um you know figuring out where
to put taxes is is is comp licated um
and just one more question and can you
uh just speak to the over production um
you know you talked about how that needs
to be prevented but how does that
contribute and how has it contributed to
the illicit Market uh in California
particular oh it's a disaster um so
California even when we legalized at the
time we legalized we were producing
about I think it was 13 million pounds
of uh cannabis and about 2 million were
estimated to be consumed in state so
California was an engine of illegal
exportation you know even before
legalization
um with legalization um the state it was
originally only supposed to license
small cultivators but they didn't
respect what was in the ballot
initiative and issued more licenses to
large cultivators so we ended up with
both huge illegal
cultivation um and legal cultivators who
were producing more than what the legal
system could absorb and therefore
started to look for Outlets uh for what
they were producing legally um outside
of the legal system um so that has led
to Falling prices on the legal Market um
cultivators who invest in in creating
infrastructure failing um you know it's
it's been a very very messy and that's
happened in many states uh across the
country um that either issued excessive
numbers of legal licenses California was
particularly complicated because we
already had such huge infrastructure but
the elicit Market's actually grown in
California um in recent years uh because
enforcement has declined and many Das
are reluctant to
pursue um illegal sales um or the guy
gets you know fine there's one story I
got told the guy got an $800,000 fine
showed up the next day with a suitcase
with $800,000 in cash and delivered it
uh you know so so even high fines are
are sometimes not effective so it's um
it's a major you know we've seen human
trafficking violence uh a lot of um
problems associated with um excess
production on both sides uh particularly
elicit but also even on the legal Market
um so i' just say if you don't have that
huge illegal production going on here
now and I actually don't know um what
your situation is um just be uh um you
want to try and help transition your
producers to Legal production but you
want to be careful um the public
Monopoly or public lead approach could
be applied to the whole thing to
cultivation manufacturing and retailing
Quebec just focused it on the retailing
sector um I think that's the most
important that you you know sort of
choke point that you want to control um
you can have um how you handle
cultivation and Manufacturing is another
issue I'd say that's that might be less
essential to be one last thing could you
just tell us about the website your
website our website yes what you have on
it it's uh called getting it right from
the
start.org um and I think it's on the
materials one of the pages I handed out
to you at the bottom um and thank you
doctor I appreciate that just to let you
know our tobacco tax is down
10% State of New Hampshire I know this
is the Live Free or Die state so um yes
thank you Dr Silver I I love the uh
title getting it right from the start if
we don't implement the safeguards the GU
rails that you have um so eloquently put
forth do you think we'll get it
wrong yeah I think it's better to
decriminalize and live with ambiguity
like Portugal does than to um create a
huge
for-profit set of interests that are
legal I think that that's the most
dangerous in the long run
um so I try and get it right thank you
um I just wanted to let let you know all
three um subjecta experts from the
medical field agree with you that that
we heard from last last week they don't
believe we can get it right because when
you put more of an harmful addictive
substance on the ground it it it creates
more problems more addiction more mental
health issues and um suicides so thank
you thank you Doctor anything else so
I'm gonna ask where El said thank you
Doctor very much for your testimony
again if you can get any your written
testimony over to daily I very much
appreciate that I'll send that and thank
you so much for the opportunity and this
was a long time to speak with St legisl
it's unusual and I appreciate it hey
Mike I'm going to ask you to come up for
one for a couple minutes yes please I
want to ask you about the medical um
have you talk about the medical industry
and the lab testing that's done there to
kind of give us a standard of where the
therapeutic industry is in testing a
product and what the requirements look
like uh thank you Senator L So to that
that point could you just talk a little
bit about under the under the
therapeutic model what are you doing for
testing who does the testing is there
reference checks done as well um yeah
thank you um I'm Michael Hol
administrator for the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services
um the therapeutic cannabis law has a
grant of rul making Authority that
allows the department to um write rules
for testing standards uh it also
requires that uh the testing Laboratory
the test for therapeutic cannabis be
licensed um by our health facility
Administration under RSA
151 um there is one independent Testing
Lab in the state of New Hampshire uh
they're Nelson analytical they're
located in Manchester and they're
licensed by the uh another uh or uh a uh
organizational unit within the
department so basically our rules
require that every batch of can cannabis
Harvest batch of cannabis be tested for
both contaminants and cannabinoid
profile the contaminants range from
mold uh micro microb uh microbials
um heavy metals uh Etc it's a standard
panel um the this the threshold levels
have not been updated since the rules
were written back in 2014 I will you
know I'll I'll fully admit that that is
a body of work that we are that we are
working on to update those levels um but
every batch of cannabis is tested um
every concentrate batch is tested um and
over the course of the program we have
required a um uh the atcs to conduct a
robust quality assurance program um
requiring individual products to be
tested as well um the uh the lab is uh
Nelson analytical was a was an
environmental lab testing uh food water
Etc um they volunteered to enter this
business
um there is no limit on the number of
Laboratories um that are allowed to test
for cannabis in the state of New
Hampshire um but no other Testing
Laboratories have come to the for to uh
Engage The atc's in uh in in in testing
and and get a license
um so the only last question I have is
because you covered everything I think
is reference testing right so who's
testing the tester right that is not a
that is not a requirement so we're
currently not doing it because it's not
in rules and it's not in law correct
they are they are ISO accredited I I
don't have the number um offand like uh
previous test uh people testifying have
but they they're ISO accredited in um
they have DEA number so they can you
know get the the Cannabis uh you know
samples from uh sources to regulate
their systems
um the
um it is not uncommon that uh B of
cannabis fail um testing you heard
testimony from the atcs that number is
about 10% um I I can't confirm uh that
number um offhand um however you know
batches of cannabis do uh uh exceed the
thresholds uh we rece the state receives
all of the testing reports proactively
um and and we manage that uh th those
those exceedances we do allow
exceedances of uh certain uh
contaminants to be remediated uh through
extraction um which uh is the basically
flour gets turned into concentrates we
test the concentrates again for those
same contaminants and and they pass
contaminate thresholds um so it's it is
true that not every you know batch that
exceeds a threshold uh needs to be
destroyed it can be remediated uh and
that's a that's a costs saver for the uh
the atcs um it's important that the the
draft that we're dealing with now has an
allowance for um remediation protocols
um for uh for failed badges one last
question before I give it to the chief
for a question costing who pays for the
costing for the testing iscs
payb 100% of the cost for each of the
tests that are required St there are no
cost of the states at all for this
program well I understand that I'm just
talking about the lab testing purposes
for this conversation around how much is
it cost for a lab that costing right now
is currently covered for testing the
$450 fee we heard was a guesstimate
batch test cost that's covered by the
ATC with the testing that's correct give
me one second
Chief thank you Mr chair uh if I Mr
chair could request that you request
DHHS to provide a comprehensive list of
the testing protocol uh listing the
contaminants pesticides and other uh
elements that they test currently uh
with this contractor to provide that to
the committee or commission sir okay
I'll give out another homework
assignment just give me a minute Tim
thank you Mr chair sh so um who who pays
for your office space and your
electricity that you use to do your work
the the patients of the program and the
atcs so we we have a cost allocation
program where we the tax AR paying any
of that correct we pay we pay uh we have
a cost allocation procedure um where uh
programs pay rent uh essentially um pay
for our heat pay for our office space
pay for our chairs uh and whatnot
um it's a it's a common um approach to
for those kinds of things uh for
programs uh like well all programs um we
we share the cost of our legal
department we share the costs of our you
know finance department uh Etc so again
I I think what he's saying is it's
similar to the liquor model it's similar
to the lottery model in that those
agencies from the revenues they receive
take out their expenses first before
delivering any Revenue to the
state is that is that correct is that a
summation that's by basic
understanding I I know that I'm paying
rent and heat and air conditioning for
my space in 29 Haz and
drive all right so I have so you have a
homework assignment right two of them I
would I would I would offer one thing uh
and that is we do not release to the
public meaning the atc's which pesticide
chemicals we test for um we keep that
confidential um so that um they don't so
that if we have a discret list MH of
pesticides that they know that we can
test for that means that if they use a
different pesticide that is not on that
on that list then they would know that
it's that it can't that that we don't
test for it and uh they might be able to
use it um and it not be uh discovered so
I would just I would offer that as a as
a note of caution that you know our
pesticide list that we test for um that
we that we work with our uh the The
Testing Lab is is not made public to the
atcs we might have a sidebar
conversation on that under under J car
I'm the vice chair J car and I'm going
to remind you your if 2014 is when you
put your rules in they're due to expire
next year you better get them get them
renewed if you hav't we've updated those
rules a number of times
since um so again so whatever rules you
have for lab testing um if we could get
those those rules out to the committee
that would be great so we could see them
and then any generic um that doesn't
doesn't cause any any release of
sensitive data for the number of batches
and percentage of batch of failures you
have in a testing cycle would be in a
given year how many tests were done how
many had failure rates would be useful
Chief yes thank you Mr chair I think
it's just a matter of comment that uh
the state uh has a vested interest in
knowing uh in in interest of full
transparency exactly what uh the testing
protocol currently is for these uh
atcs and I think that uh the members of
this commission are are well versed in
the confidentiality nature of of any
such um material but I think that the
public interest outweighs uh any
confidentiality interest here in
ensuring that um the uh regulatory
process is complet compl comprehensive
and is protecting the public currently
uh as well as being able to compare that
to what may be recommended by the
commission moving
forward I don't necessarily disagree as
I I I have a little concern that we keep
a list private from the from the atcs
and what we're testing for how how do
they know how to meet the standard if
they don't know what they're being
tested against the atcs know the only
thing the atcs don't know is that the
list of pesticide chemicals that the lab
can and currently test for and that list
has increased over time as they've
developed more protocols for various
chemicals now I
mean if if I'm asked to provide that
list to this this body then yes I'll
provide the list to the body I'll
certainly confer with my director um but
I just wanted you to know that we do not
release that list to the atc's so that
they can use chemicals that are not on
that list that are still prohibited yeah
but I'm happy
the committee Mr sh again yeah we have
the Canadian list and they're very clear
on what they test for so um again I
guess the question was how does our list
compar to their list compared to what
I've asked the other homework assignment
to do is provide me a list of what are
the contaminants and the trigger
thresholds that that would create a
failed batch if you will corre happy to
provide that list to the commission up
to the commission to determine whether
or not they want to make that list
public great okay anything else for Mike
S I just want to know how your lab
testing was done whether we had a state
lab or independent lab I would be
welcome to engage um the the the owner
of the lab if you wanted to hear more
detailed information about ISO
accreditation and anybody else have any
any technical aspects of their
business what is the rationale for
keeping this um non-public and doesn't
the public have a right to
know I believe I already answered that
question and that is if the atc's were
to have the list of chemicals that the
lab can test for that means that they
know what the lab is not testing for
which means that the atcs could use
pesticides that are not being tested for
and we would never know so that's the
rationale all right thank you
Mike um so I go I missed uh approval of
the minutes so I have a motion to
approve the minutes of September
24th Mr Mr chair there is just the
excellent minutes but there was uh on
bullet number seven it's it's incomplete
it says adolescents who experience
cannabis induced psychosis and do not
stop are likely to conver convert to and
let me get a motion then we can have a
conversation right so I need a motion to
approve then we can amend and adjust as
we need but I need a motion to approve
the minutes first first and then we'll
have a discussion about the minutes and
if we been moved by Senator Whitley
second by representative kahill to adopt
the minutes as written uh for October
24th 2023 and Now comments on the
minutes yes um there's a need to amend
the minutes on page two under Dr Amy
turn Cliff's Neuroscience uh testimony
if you go to Bullet number seven it it
reads adolescence who experience
cannabis induced psychosis do not stop
are likely to convert to and it's blank
it's an incomplete sentence uh it should
say convert to
schizophrenia if if the minutes could be
amended to read I'd appreciate it thank
you any other changes to the
minutes than so all those in favor of
adopting the minutes as amended signify
by saying I I oppose nay abstain and one
abstention minutes are adopted all right
so
let's quickly talk about future meetings
for a minute about if do do we have a
need to bring anybody else in and then
we're going to start going through the
bill my goal would be to go to 12:30 um
so 45 minutes to just continue through
the bill um after we figure out whether
or not we want any other speakers is any
other information we think we need at
this point or will the next meeting just
be continuing through the
bill
yep um Mr chair I think at our original
meeting one of the uh departments we
wanted to hear from was the New
Hampshire uh Treasury Department I i'
like to I'm sorry which one New
Hampshire treasury treasury the treasury
is I think we need to know how we're
going to handle illegal
money thank
you I'll put a request out to see if
they'll come in and speak to our
committee I I can't guarantee they will
but I will make the request thank you Mr
chair um I I believe uh Mr Mara had
spoken in our first meeting
perhaps uh having someone from Quebec if
we could find the person from the Quebec
folks to come in and in light of uh Miss
Silver's Miss Silver's uh testimony
today with respect to her opinion of the
Quebec model um particularly one that is
being the most effective profitable in
Canada perhaps it may be worthwhile to
have a representative one would be
willing to come to New Hampshire from
Quebec to talk about how their model is
is it
works I would have I'll have I'll give
it to that's a homework assignment I'm
gonna give to Chairman abis um and he
can take care of see if he can find
somebody who's willing to come in and
speak and again any member who knows
somebody who might be willing to come in
and speak on that from Quebec on their
model then just get the name and and
again we can bring them in next month or
next meeting May I defer to Dave Mara I
I think Dave had been in contact with
someone from Quebec um
so if you want Dave if you want to make
a request if he wants to come in and
speak and because Quebec did a state
model if I remember right um and they
can talk about their state model and
pros and cons what worked and what
didn't and if they're willing to come in
so now Daryl doesn't get the assignment
you
do all right so that's our we have two
speakers we'll reach out to the New
Hampshire Treasury and we'll have and
Dave will see if he can find somebody
from Quebec to speak about the Quebec
State model they did there um with that
we're going to take a five minute recess
we going to go use the restroom come
back and we're going to go jump right
into the bill and start off where we uh
continue on where we left off last
week
oh
that's
light
right
so if there's anybody from public that
wants to chat about anything they heard
or or um recommendations before we start
in we'll continue
on if not not seeing anybody we're gonna
again jump right back in so I think
we're on page five of uh the draft Bill
we left off with possession limit and a
discussion around that I'm not sure I
was going to leave that alone for today
because I do think that's a bigger
conversation as we see further on what
that looks like in the bill so I'd
recommend we just skip over possession
limit and go down to start with public
place number
22 is there any comments on the
definition of public
place go ahead Tim I mean this do does
this include the roads like ways so it
would so again uh Chief over there could
probably tell you public a public way
public place what what a better
definition is as it relates to our
criminal statutes but yes a public place
is generally anywhere accessible so it
be sidewalks roads
um even restaurants that's if it's a
public place that the Public's allowed
Ingress it doesn't include private and
closed places
so that that would be generally correct
uh private um Property Owners would uh
like a residential property owner would
have um the right to exercise um on
their on their property for example in
your backyard for example but uh in a
public place is essentially any place
that the public has a right to be
without
permission um so that's essentially
sidewalks public ways uh public uh uh
public buildings government buildings
Town buildings uh essentially anything
that is not private space
right good so how does that relate with
like say your personal vehicle on a
public space and I'm asking
because um
we've had an abnormal amount of traffic
fatalities recently and the highest
number of motorcycle crashes
um killing killing motorcycle riders
this year and I met with a group of
motorcycle riders last night um and I I
wanted to know a large group of
motorcycle riders and I wanted to know
what their thoughts on on that were and
and they came up with an interesting
statement they were talking about hands
handsfree and and and it's my
observation that these vaporizers things
and cars are not handsfree and um you
know I just I just want to kind of
understand you know we're going to be
talking about penalties and and things
like that and and and limitations and
and I definitely don't want to see
people smoking in their car if it's
technically a a private thing and we
really need to be strong I think I think
jumping you jumped ahead on page seven
there's a specific prohibition on
smoking in a car so that would be
different than so we what we'll get to
about the prohibition piece but um so
even so a public way again no one while
no one has access to your car inside of
your vehicle right we have a specific
exemption saying even inside your
vehicle though you can't smoke it's a we
recognize it's a private place but you
still can't smoke inside your vehicle so
we can talk about that when we get there
so this is outside of that
provision so 22 is okay 23 premises
means that includes all parts of a
contiguous real estate occupied by a li
liy over which the ly has direct and
indirect control or interest and which
the ly uses in the operation of a
licensed business which has been
approved by the commission as a proper
place in which to exercise the lenes
privilege any it's the building right
it's the building uh any any question
about that or any
changes good
there number 24 resident means a natural
person who a is domiciled in New
Hampshire and B maintains a place of ab
boode in New Hampshire unless the
individual was homeless and residing in
New Hampshire at least 51% of the time
so any def any concern about Resident
Chief yes yes Mr chair I I would propose
that we redact on uh subsection B uh the
words unless the individual is homeless
and residing in New Hampshire for at
least 51% of the time um this this
particular legislation uh needs to be uh
spec specific with respect to who a
resident is um and maintaining a place
of abod in New Hampshire consistent with
how we treat residents for tax purposes
as well as registration motor vehicle
operation would be consistent I think
more with where we need to be than uh
referencing homeless
folks or are transient and oftentimes
have no
identification yeah yeah I I agree I
don't think we I I think it's a slippery
slope to be modifying the definition of
Resident um because you know this can be
referenced and used later down the line
on like say a resident for voting and I
don't want to go down that slippery
slope so I guess the issue is I got to
see how the word resident used later on
in the bill which is I think some of the
problem right so um so I'm okay with
again if if the committee is okay with
removing that that's fine but just
understand we may have to revisit it if
we go back and look at a given statute
that says something about Resident
because then technically we'd be
excluding every homeless person from
possibly this law right if if it says a
resident shall not and we've we've now
to set a a homeless person is not
classified as a resident um that could
be a problematic for us yeah well Mr
chair I think in going forward uh in the
bill there there are references as you
indicated um with respect to how to
prove residency
right um and a homeless person uh based
on again going um ahead which were not
there yet and and I I believe that you
know there there would
be it would be impossible to to
establish residency if the intent here
is to uh to find a resident someone who
lives in New Hampshire by way of
documentation that's presented further
in the bill and I think that perhaps at
least put an asteris here or redact it
for the time being based on what the
requirements to produce residency are
included in uh further on so so daily
I'm going to give you a homework
assignment um can you take a look at it
maybe call out everywhere in the bill
where the word resident is use so we can
make sure that this homeless piece
doesn't cause any kind of conflict and I
you know we we don't want to create I
don't think that we want to as a
legislature want to create a new
definition of who is a resident there's
ample reference to the definition of
resident in state law so I I don't know
I don't I wouldn't suggest that we
create a new definition so let's just
take a look where it's used in the in
further see if we need to leave it
whether we just strike the entire
definition of Resident because it'll be
used whatever the standard definition is
for everything else in state law or
whether we modify this one so if we just
take a look daily let's take a look at
that great so we're going to skip over
number 24 until we get get a little
further answer I'm sorry had a question
I think the was just jumping in saying
we want to make sure we don't exclude
homeless people yeah just I I believe
I've seen this in other sections of the
code so I think it we I'd be happy to
take that on as a homework assignment to
go back and see where else in the code
it defines resident sure and come back
with daily you take a look at the bill
and see where it is and if you would
take a look at other statutes where we
have resent required all right so we're
out of the
definitions yeah well I'm gonna we're
not quite out um I in your handout just
to um there's a couple definitions we
gave to the doctor that was here last
week um she was unable to attend because
the New Hampshire Medical Society is
having their annual meeting this week um
Friday through Sunday and so she was
unable to attend but she did her
homework assignment sent it back into us
um so if you want to take a look well
she has you'll see some definitions of
draft Bill reviewed and distributed at
the meeting and she's talking about line
four on page four for line 26 was one of
the definitions and it was Cannabis
products to find
it
y yeah so it's number number um eight in
your um definition in your definition
list so she re
re-qualify um and says Count's product
means any product containing
parts of a plant genus cannabis
containing over uh 3% THC on dry weight
basis cannabis products shall not
include seeds of the genus cannabis hemp
or hemp products as defined
by does that definition work for
everybody so uh Mr sherff a question um
in light of U Miss Silver's uh testimony
with respect to the various analoges I'm
going to refer to that as these as
analog of THC and can abono canabo THC P
THC deltaed H
um if if we want to as a commission make
recommendations as to what a cannabis
product is perhaps and to close the
loophole that apparently exists um in
cabil mwe that's now being exploited by
retailers perhaps maybe we again put an
asterisk there and come back and look at
whether or not we want to include some
of these other
um products um that are being sold
currently that have intoxicating
elements to them so I I think if you
look at the bottom of this page we're
looking at there's a conversation about
nope the of the doctor's handout
definitions she has hemp and she talks
about those other things relative to
hemp right so I think this is
specifically talking about um cannabis
based not hemp based product
right
what I think the chief is talking about
is not the hemp based products per se
but the analog to uh THC products the
Deltas right I've run in you've run not
you we have run into this issue and
trying to make a laundry list either by
chemical composition or whatever you
only have to change one or two uh
component elements and it's legal so the
language needs to be broad enough to
include mhm but not exclude
CBD exactly and that's often times what
we found with fentanyl and some of the
other uh illicit drugs where chemists
exploit uh the molecular structure to
create a product that is essentially
producing the same effect but is not
particularly defined so that's what I
think we're referring to here is looking
at um making sure that it's broad enough
um from from a molecular and from a
legal
standpoint so what's interesting is in
in the one in the Senate Bill 180 um
there's a line just at the end or any
other THC isomer
variant which would deal with any other
version in case like right now we have
Delta 8 and Delta 9 God knows what else
we might end up and there a Delta 10 as
well um maybe that line would would
would just Encompass you know if you
have a THC or THC like you know where
where I didn't see that where does that
so that's in Senate Bill 180 when we
were talking about the hemp products and
the and the and the dry weight of Delta
9 Delta 8 THC in allowed allowed amounts
and it just says that's that's that's a
separate bill that's not this bill right
but my question is whether we add that
line to be consistent or any other THC
isomer variant yes where it says you
know so again if you read uh it would
read cannabis products means any product
containing parts of the plant genus
cannabis containing over point I think
it's supposed to be 03 not3 yeah
03 um
THC or any um of THC or any other THC
isomer variant and then continue on with
the sentence on a dry weight basis right
so that would take care of um any
deviation or variation I was I would ask
the AG's office to just take a look at
that language determine whether or not I
don't think we've had any cases on point
maybe they have are aware to make sure
that that is a language that uh can
that's enforcable okay no the the
question I have on that is ISO
variant uh is that I was ask the lb
people yeah is that that because I'm not
quite sure what I I assume it means a
derived fun a term of art or jargon
correct yes well if it's a ter of art
then it stands on its
own all right so we'll consider adding
that line but I'll get I'll ask C AG
whether or not that's an enforceable
comment right because I think we're what
we what we've heard is that there is a
plethora of synthetic cabon oids now
that are that are now coming out uh that
would be difficult to prove up under
that
definition and again just again we have
to see where cannabis products are being
used further on but this is more an
Enforcement issue for the Liquor
Commission and in their rules and
regulations about their managing and
control
ring so all right so we'll we'll look at
that line we'll ask C AG for an opinion
on that and then we'll come back so
looking at the doctor's next one which
is line 30 page8 and the definition
of number one I don't know where that is
yeah definition of marijuana but I'm
surprised it's all the way back in page
30 yeah um so but it's a definition so
it's under the personal possession uh
component and and it just says say
marijuana includes the leaves flowers of
all species of the genus plant cannabis
containing over and I think that's
supposed to be
0.03% of THC and we may want to again
include that same or any THC isomer
variant um on the dryway basis and it
goes on and includes all the different
derivatives and and those kind of things
Mr chair
yes right yeah yeah yeah yeah we
adjusted it because in her definition
she uses three and I think we're saying
it's supposed to be zero 0
Z she has a correct corre her definition
is correct yes okay 0.3
right just for statory construction do
we want to put that definition in the
move it to the definition
section um Mr chair you've now got two
definition you got two words for the
same product I was concerned about that
cannabis product and marijuana in theory
are the same exact thing but and the
secondary definition marijuana is a
derogatory
term that was specifically created to
denigrate a particular group of
individuals problem is this this is a
um what so this part of the chapter is
actually around well the criminal
statutes exactly so products yeah I
think it's talking about I I I see the
point but it is talking about two
different things because we're actually
talking about the produ the products
that are made from this plant I guess Mr
chairman I suggest that if you just say
that the um the term
marijuana is a
um quot ter qu that word for uh cannabis
products therefore you're using cannabis
products all the definitions of cannabis
products are then adhering to the use of
that other
word I I think the problem is when we're
talking I actually don't know this the
criminal statute it's what it's referred
to right marij okay yeah so that that's
so we so we don't need we'd have to
rewrite the entire right so we don't
need 318 statute if we decide to
reference cannabis Pro so we don't need
we don't need maybe the the solution is
we don't need a separate definition for
marijuana in page 30 we have a defition
for cannabis we have a definition for
cannabis products and there's likely a
definition in the in the criminal
statute yeah my my only point is that if
we tie the two words together we're
taking the definitions and and tying
them together at that point so you're
not changing you don't have to change
all the others you just say use General
language uh no other section of law
withstanding uh the use of uh the
phraseology marijuana or marijuana
products refers to cannabis or cannabis
products and there therefore you've
covered everything we don't have to
rewrite everything we've got it in one
place
done I got your your point yeah let's
let's have that conversation I think
when we get to that section okay let's
move we'll just just pay attention to
that we'll get when we get to that page
30 we'll we'll take it up but I think
that that's a probably a bad idea myself
um because we'd have to rewrite the
entire three 18 Satur and everywhere
marijuana is referenced I'm not sure
that the
Cannabis um definition cannabis products
definition meets the same definition as
marijuana
so just just one thing that came to my
mind when we're talking about adding the
section about cannabis products the the
words to Encompass the the artificial
cannabis
synthetic we we're are we anticipating
that my for my inum we're anticipating
that the product that's going to be sold
at these stores are plant grown so by
adding that into the definition of
cannabis prod products are we making it
all right would we be making it legal
for the franchisees to be selling
selling that you see my
point it it depends I think later on in
the legislation as to what the
legislation will Define as products that
can be sold right so I think in the
broader sense uh perhaps this section
deals with the broad definition of what
it is later on in the legislation there
would be language concerning what
cannabis products are to be allowed to
be sold as opposed to what products
could not be sold but if we I'm just
saying if we're saying cannabis products
with defining it and then if somebody
goes back to what the definitions of
what what can we
sell well again so that's going to be
regulated by Lottery and Li by I keep
saying Lottery sorry liquor
um but again I my my this this is merely
containing products that saying that
anything that contains THC greater than
the 3% right but uh to his point Mr
chair maybe we could add um cannabis
product mean any product at the end of
that first sentence comma as further
defined in regulation or as further
defined by the electric commissioner
approved cannabis products uh would
would probably cover it right if you add
the word approved or authorized cannabis
product but by whom well I think that's
going to be covered later on in some
enabling legislation that decides who's
going to write regory stuff that gives
uh liquor the right to but if you're
going to stay approved you want to be
more prescriptive about by home all
right let's leave it as those two
sentences those two definitions as open
to see how they're used later on in the
uh in the bill and then we can come back
and visit and I will have a conversation
with the AG and and see what they
say just just want to flag as well in
our packets that we got today new
Futures has a new handout for everyone
it's helpful just for reviewing going
forward from a public health standpoint
all right
um we're just running through
definitions still we're just getting to
we got to the end I think and we're just
talking to the doctor's homework
assignment um and their definitions
um let's put aside the doctors because
she references things that are later on
in the bill and we'll come back to the
doctor's homework after we've gotten to
that section to see how it how it works
in there so let's go on
to um page six personal use of
cannabis so just we'll take item one um
in as in a whole section and entertain
any comments about uh section one of 318
DF colon 2 personal use of
cannabis so here we have uh we talk we
set the age restrictions of you have to
be 21 or
older
um
in section A we just talk about basic
possession consumption and using that
isn't illegal on its own as a standard
unless we have some
other Provisions down the road like in
section A Mr chair I just offer up
perhaps tightening up uh this would be
on line
15 where it says capacity as a and I
would add new New Hampshire licensed
staffer of a add New Hampshire cannabis
product that restricts exactly who we're
talking about so it's a re New Hampshire
licensed person as opposed to just any
person
okay so on line 15 I think you're saying
capacity as a staff or of a licensed
cannabis product man manufacturer and
New Hampshire license
right da you get that
one thank you B any comments on B yes go
ahead what's the definition of
transferring if I make some brownies and
have a party am I transferring to an
underage person unknown to
me
my argument is yes you would be
violating the law right no different
than alcohol are you have a party and
you have friends over and you let a kid
go get a beer from the fridge or kid
goes against a beer fridge and you don't
know about it you're still obligated
under your license under your premises
so okay but that I think that should be
that that when you're saying
transferring what we're what we're doing
is defining transferring to include that
language I think the chief has a comment
Chief yeah uh Mr chair and uh thank you
uh I would be opposed this language can
be construed as gifting right and this
opens up a plethora of issues with
respect to gifting and transferring
without
remuneration uh cannabis products so uh
I would be opposed to section b as it
stands uh simply because it enables
enables
gifting SE
not sorry correct this would this would
legalize the
transfer you know of of marijuana from
one person to another under 21 who met
all the conditions and controls so you
can't give it to I mean over 21 you
can't give it you can give it you could
transfer mar mar marijuana in my
possession I could hand it to Daryl if
he wanted it and I could walk away as
long as I didn't ask for
renumeration and the question is whether
we want to make that legal or
illegal I think the other question is
Maybe the Attorney General's off if you
don't mind do we need to have the word
like knowing like is it is a strict
liability um for a excuse me for a
criminal statute if it's not addressed
specifically in the statute then
statutary construction would read in the
knowing uh mental state so um you don't
have to include it if you want to to do
anything other than a knowing default uh
then you'd want to want to specify that
but if it's left unsaid then it would
have to be at least a knowing mental
state well Chief Becky do you have
something there no I was just Notting in
agreement I just saw your light on it I
was just thinking U was brought up
transferring I think all of us remember
in uh College smoking Ops uh other
people's cigarettes
uh something that routinely you never
did no no okay no idea what you're
talking about
um so from the AG's office the question
of adding a a a mental state knowingly
is that necessary or not necessary the
default assumption is that absent that
the standard is
knowingly yes that's correct thank
you Chief did you have something else no
I would just again I just uh when you
open the door to gifting uh in the
language that's included in section B um
it it flies in the face of what we've
heard today from Miss silver and others
with respect to encouraging the transfer
I think the state wants to ensure that
whatever products are being sold are
sold to people that are responsible and
those folks uh that are legally able to
possess so we'll leave that question
mark we'll come back and address it
because we have at least one objection
to that section so we can come back and
see if we want to address it and take a
boat um so the trans from Cannabis
includes cannabis products to a cannabis
testing facility that won't be illegal
if you're transporting for that purpose
and giving are we talking about transfer
or trans and see we do we actually mean
transporting well I think the
transporting is later on we have a
definition and some stuff in language
relative to that this is just
understanding that while you might have
a licensed transport you're going to
give the product to somebody else in
this case a testing facility we want to
make sure that that's not somehow
construed as being illegal okay I think
transferring luji implies that the
person from point A to point B is a
change in ownership
right um D um controlling property where
the acts described under the section
occur not sure what are you trying to
get to
there I have no idea what that means I
have no
idea you have any idea what that
means well it's a reference I think if
you're in control the the the house
where it happens but I'm not sure why
that
would so I guess if you're allowing if
you own a house or a property and you
allow miners on you know you let your
kids have a party and let all the
underage kids start smoking there but
we're listing here those acts that are
not
illegal yeah I'm just not sure why I'm
not sure what that statute what that
section does or why it's
there
anybody hold on
Matt please bail us
out maybe this is relative to
cultivators thank you Mr chairman for
the record Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis I happen to be familiar with
the Advent of the section which was
written I believe specifically to
prevent the kinds of gifting that we've
seen in the District of Columbia and in
other states that do not yet have
regulated markets uh so first of all I
think you have to legalize transferring
because otherwise it could be cons it
could be a criminal offense to pass
somebody a joint or to hand somebody a
small amount of cannabis so I think
everybody agrees that shouldn't be a
criminal offense generally what we were
seeing in DC in other states with uh no
regulated market was okay I can't sell
you cannabis but I'll sell you a t-shirt
for $100 and the T-shirt comes with a
half ounce of cannabis so this was very
openly happening companies were
advertising that this was what they were
doing and this language is intended to
make it very clear that that's not legal
that a transfer without remuneration is
legal and a transfer for remuneration is
not does that make sense right but we
were talking under Section d That's
controlling property where the acts
described under this section
occur so okay I'm sorry I thought you
were still talking about B and C and
there were some question about gifting
and and what what this was about so I
think we're clear there I think D we're
trying to understand what is controlling
property where the acts described under
the section occur don't know what that
does if I may offer perhaps this means
that um if you're permitting legal use
that you must be p a person that
controls that property to permit the
legal
use in other words
uh someone could not be um allowed to
use um and prohibited from use without a
person that's actually controlling that
property in other words someone else who
doesn't live there says oh yeah you can
smoke on the property um and then you
but that person doesn't own the
property but this specifies the legality
that reflects the owner of the property
making the decision as to whether or not
the legal it's it's legal use that goes
to
if a private property owner wants to
permit uh use as it is permitted under
law on in that in that private property
they can do so so let's is that but that
language is it needed because my thought
is let's say we're talking about like a
beer I don't want someone drinking beer
at my house I I my next step is if I ask
them to leave if they don't leave
they're
trespass but you're controlling the
property what this says is that you must
be the controller of the property in
other words you must have a legal right
to control the property as opposed to
someone who's in your house says oh no I
don't want you to have beer in Mr abb's
House okay so I think you guys are
saying the same thing and I think that
this is not necessary because it's sort
of covered an existing law is not
necessary so let's do this this came out
of house bill 639 which representative
hunt was in control of so why don't we
wait till he's here we'll take I think d
and e because E I think is another one
assisting a person who's under 21 years
or older in any of the acts described
under the section but the section is
talking about legal legal consumption so
I don't know why and that would be
conspiracy let's just let's hold for
representative the HT to see why he put
this in 639 he may have a very
legitimate reason I don't quite get I
was thinking the controlling property
piece might be about manufacturers
having a a building full of marijuana
cannabis products and making sure that's
not illegal that they have a building
full of marijuana so um even if they
aren't con assuming in their possession
and you control the building so
therefore I I'm not sure so let's just
talk to John and see where he was going
with that provide they're not needed
they they should be stricted they cover
them
right all right so uh so d& we're going
to hold and for representative hunt and
I'll ask a homework question for
him
yes sure step up and hit the microphone
and continue
on and just introduce yourself so we get
up the sure Pat suvin uh retired chief
of GS toown worked on the drug task
force for two years and currently the
executive director for the Chiefs
Association 318b colon
26 addresses control of premise and
makes it illegal for a person to control
a premise or a vehicle where there's
marijuana kept used or
stored what this is doing is eliminating
that so what it's doing is taking that
out of 12 uh colon 26 and making it
legal to use a vehicle in this case a
vehicle for or home for storage so I
believe that's where this is addressing
it should perhaps we should just repeal
that section I wrote it down we'll come
back as thank you Chief thank you
Chief all right so we're on to section
two no law enforcement employed by an
agency that receives state or local
government fund shall expand any state
or local expand any state or local
resource including officer's time to
affect an arrest or C of cannabis or
conduct any investigation on the sole
basis of the activity officer believes a
constitute violation of federal law and
it goes on that's Sanctuary policy
that's a sanctuary policy I have to be
honestly I oppose this myself I would
like to strike this language um uh
because again we have um the assistance
of Federal Officer who have safety
concerns and safety issues and they may
be ex affecting a raid of some sort for
an elal grow under federal law that
we're not doing under state law for
whatever reason and I would not want to
limit local police departments and state
police departments from providing Aid
which has information and resources that
could
be could be uh help reduce risk to
officers yeah thank you this would
significantly restrict if not prohibit
uh state and local and County Law
Enforcement from enforcing or assisting
uh or enforcing even current state law
with respect to illicit illegal
non-permitted manufacturing growing or
dispensing well this talks specifically
about Federal right so in violation of
federal law so it's not enforcing state
law it's it's about helping anybody who
might be a if if the DEA came in and
said we need you to help we we have this
giant grow that we know about we want to
executed search warrant you would
prohibit every law enforcement a agent
in the entire state from helping the
DEA act on an illicit um enforcement of
correct and and there's there's an
overarching need to ensure that state
and local law enforcement continue to be
coordinated with federal law enforcement
um when those federal law enforcement
agents take action Mr
chair yeah I understand but but at the
same time it says sole purpose mariju uh
cannabis yeah Mr chairman I think both
the sole purpose and that this is very
limiting it's just in compliance with
this chapter so we're not talking about
marijuana grows that are illegal under
New Hampshire law we're talking about
only situations that are fully legal
under New Hampshire law that they can't
participate or Aid the federal
government and so I think that's
something we would want to have where if
something's fully legal under our laws
why would we be be supporting the
federal government in their attempts to
enforce something that's u in compliance
with new hampture law this is very
limiting language is all I'm trying to
say and it's a sole basis and only
within the confines of what's fully
legal in New Hampshire should we could
we specify that there has to be state
law violation of some
sort well again you know um you're
you're you're closing the door on an
appropriate coordination of efforts of
law enforcement to enforce federal law
that would not be
consistent uh or would be inconsistent
with state law if there's uh bringing up
your original comment if there was a 500
acre illicit grow and the federal
authorities were going to pursue that
right um it would be in the state's best
interest and the municipality's best
interest to participate in that effort
that would be fully legal under this
definition because well it depends on
how you constr the language and the
language is it's not in compliance with
New Hampshire law then it's not in
compliance with New Hampshire law then
they can can then they can work with the
federal government so we're limiting
here to just what is not in compliance
with New Hampshire law let's just say
I'm I'm operating one the I'm a
franchisee and I'm 100% complying with
state law could the local law
enforcement or the county or the state
police work with the DEA to close my
store down I'm not violating any state
law I guess that's the concern is
um I see both both sides of it I think
as written we can this needs to be
cleaned up either way it needs to
specify you know there has to be some
type of violation of state law but and
in that case again I mean we have we
have enforcement of our state laws so
like we would
want our enforcement deal with that
right but do we want if there's no state
law violation are we comfortable not
just letting that kind of
the up up for GRS I guess I also don't
want to discourage the the cooperation
between local and federal law
enforcements I see both
eyes Dave um I'm just looking at this as
a former Chief of Police in Manchester
my reading of this would be when any
federal agency comes in and they want to
uh do an operation or they want to do
some
enforcement I'd be prohibited from
monitoring it I'd be prohibited from uh
being there I have my officers be there
um and also prohibited from giving them
information uh maybe the person might be
dangerous that they're dealing with
maybe uh for safety purposes we want to
tell them do it at this time and do it
at that time this just ties the hands of
local law enforcement and are we going
to do this for everything we going to do
this for immigration when are we going
to do this for uh gun uh federal gun
control it just opens up a door and
uh I I believe it ties the hands of uh
uh local law enforcement officers in the
in the Chiefs to be able to control what
goes on in their
municipalities and that's my point with
respect to coordination right uh we need
to remain coordinated in law enforcement
there's unfortunately a lot of cases
that we just recently seen in another
state where coordination perhaps is is
is is more needed and um to former Chief
mayor's Point uh there's no Chief in
this state that wants Federal
authorities to to be operating a a
potentially dangerous situation in their
Community without local law enforcement
participation take Frank I say I think
if working off what Senator abis was
talking about I think if we just clarify
that this if it's a violation of state
law then that's fully appropriate like
we would have no concern with that but I
think this is just a public policy
statement as well that it's not
appropriate for you know State actors to
be enforcing like a legal franchise
going after a legal franchise just if
the feds are coming in and trying to do
that it would be it would be highly
inappropriate I think for for State
actors to be involved in that I guess if
the state is the one that's granting the
the the
franchise and then if the state police I
not saying they're doing it but then the
state police then work with the federal
government to shut me down
basically making my franchise they can
take all the inventory they basically
put me out of business I'm I'm just I'm
not sure the state it's just a conflict
there something I'm not saying that
that's what would happen I but I think
what the chief saying is also a concern
if there going to be a raid or whatever
a warrant executed do you want well
sorry we can't help you good good luck
so can we balance the two of those I I'm
just I I find it hard to believe the
state would be involved I so I get that
part of it I
get but I don't I don't want any law
enforcement be end danger than maybe
that's your homework assignment to come
up with something that balances the
interest well I have written sanct
policies before that have passed and
become lost Senator Lang has been giving
out
my well I I know with with Firearms we
made it clear that it had to be um if
it's if it's inconsistent with our state
law there needs to be something there
some type of violation but it didn't
really address the issue I just brought
up because I think it's important to
remember here all we're talking about
here are State licensed actors and so it
would be you know we're assuming that
those State act licensed actors are
acting in Faith or something like that
then they're outside the law then
they're not protected but we're
literally just talking about State
licensed actors
here I'm going to give again so again
the federal government coming in under
some sort of broader Rico type of
operation right that includes a licensed
opery who's working but that his
cultivation model may play into the RICO
Act are we going to tell them cops can't
do that because there's not a federal
statute he not violating State Statute
they're all within they've got a license
they're procuring cannabis and the feds
come in and go FBI comes in says we're
conducting a RICO investigation on this
cannabis grower because of other issues
we want you to help us is are we
restricted from helping them no because
they're within they're within they're
within this statute of Legally growing
cannabis right so we would say they
you've got the you've got the restrictor
and that restrictor is very tight IT
Deals Only with cannabis products it
doesn't deal with any other type of
criminal investigation and it's very
possible that you can have a Reco case
that would
involve a grower it's possible you could
have a RICO case involving a uh a
grocery store that uh sells beer and
wine very possible now in reality would
if if something like this where where
was doomsday snaro goes down wouldn't
liquor enforcer be consulted during the
process as well I mean I'm Miss saying
because that's that's where I'm well not
necessarily I mean they don't have to be
but I I would assume that they would
they well you would assume but not
necessarily I mean their their resources
restricted but the major problem with
this section uh and any iteration of it
is exactly what Chief mea indicated and
that is is that it separates local and
federal law enforcement from
coordinating uh operations that may
imperil and impact the public safety of
the people that I'm responsible for in
my community and that's not a good thing
ever if I could add if I could add to
that in these circumstances uh if it's
just federal law we're not going to be
enforcing it anyway and to say in the
way this reads doesn't talk about
licensed anybody it just says that
anything to do with uh basically
marijuana that's not a violation of uh
state law we can't we can't uh
participate in we can't make sure it's a
safe situation we can't provide traffic
control control around we it ties our
hands and it says that local police have
no control of the situation this this
law just takes everything out of our
hands and it's unnecessary because we
can't enforce federal law on our own
anyway
so this is just unnecessary to have in
there the elect commission takes
exception to saying the chief saying
that the commission's resources are
limited in any way that's that's sort of
gratuitous well we're going to try to
help with the re and listen there's more
resources to come in I think measuring
what you have today this you you have
much bigger um much more responsibility
so I think I'm talking about five years
in the future now so but you know I
think in the future I think it's
important to make sure that that if you
think there's inadequate resources it's
the legislator job to make sure there is
adequate because this a big thing that I
am concerned about with a lot of these
Canabis bills is the enforceability of
the laws and if we have someone an
entity that's supposed to assign with
enforcement they need to be have the
resources to do that I'm just asking
assuming they have the resources
wouldn't they be contacted before
there's some type of well certainly if
it affects an authority under their
purview uh they would be um uh contacted
for sure uh we contact uh liquor
routinely whenever there's violations
that we come in contact with or
investigate at locations that dis
expense liquor that's that's that's
normal that's a normal part of law
enforcement coordination but my point
was to say that there is not a law
enforcement agency in this country today
that's not challenged with resources I
don't care who it is uh but this
particular section has nothing to do
with resources it has all to do with
coordination between agencies and
prohibiting Municipal County and state
law enforcement from having an impact on
the protection of the citizens that
they're responsible for uh in their
communities but but I'm asking if if the
local police are going to be assisting
the federal agents in executing a
warrant which I assume there was would
have been some investigation done and
it's really only a violation of federal
law there's no state law violation I'm
just asking wouldn't I I would be
surprised to know that liquor wasn't
notified
of that or they wouldn't be notified in
that's if you're presuming that it's a
federal investigation they will advise
who they want to advise they don't even
have to advis the municipalities when
they come in they do so as a matter of
courtesy uh because they have
overarching authority within the state
of New Hampshire because State of New
Hampshire is within the United States
clearly so I think again before we go
too far down rapital so
Dave me I I
can as as a chief if a federal agency
would come into the City and they would
conduct any kind of raid or make any
kind of arrest that wasn't
just that that didn't cause a safety
issue but if if there would be held to
pay because I would call that agency and
I would demand that next time they come
in that they let us know they're going
to be there so we we're apprised of that
I can think of another situation that's
a violation of federal law but it isn't
a violation of state law right somebody
um if if somebody is a uh legally uh
owns guns and they have marijuana on
them that's a fragile offense there's so
many things that go back and forth here
but this this is basically just taking
any taking the authority and any power
from local police and I don't think we
should be mandating what police can and
can't do outside of what we we already
have and what is constitu let's do this
let's let's darl why don't you do your
homework assignment and rewrite this
other people have had their hands up so
it would be next
remember you all voted me the chair
unanimously listen I I want to make sure
because we can I think we there's a
chance we can balance this if there is
if not then we'll put it to vot of
committee yeah I think and I think Chief
to to your point I think what we were
talking about here are only licensed
because this is only protecting agency
or entities that would either be a grow
that has a license to be a grower a
seller that has a license to be a seller
so if if feds are going this would only
limit cooperation in those narrow
instances so if the federal government
is coming in and going after one of
those entities it would be be it would
and and the state entity or the local
entity weren't allowed to engage in that
process it would only be if that local
if that um franchisee is fully compliant
with New Hampshire law doing nothing
wrong and the federal government still
wants to go after them then the state
couldn't participate so talk super see
that there there's there strange
situations that occur and in your
example Chief
it's from the AG's office so just to
that point this is in 318 F2 so this is
um this isn't referring to or isn't in
the same title as the rest of the uh the
bill um I think that what how this could
be read would be anybody who is for
example in in 1A possessing consuming or
using regardless of source uh because
it's not defining what whether or not
it's in compliance so um the the
Assumption in two relating to uh law
enforcement uh restriction on being able
to engage uh you'd have to Define well
what's the source in order to understand
that you'd have to to understand the
entirity of the federal action um of
whether there are any charges outside of
what would be in compliance which is
just possession or or consumption here
uh and know that before you would be
having to make a call about whether you
be uh violating the section by providing
any Aid or failing to provide any Aid so
I think that this is at risk of being
over inclusive over broad by um sort of
having an incentive for law enforcement
to not engage even if there is a basis
or there's a belief that that it
wouldn't be covered just the language
itself is is Broad and I think we'd be
fine with that if there's any I mean if
there is concern that this is not fully
clear in this section we'd be fine with
that and clarifying that we're only
concerned about going after or using
this as a pretext to go after things
that are fully legal in New Hampshire
and so I think anything we can do to
clarify that would be totally
appropriate from our perspective
homework assignment and if you don't
mind I know we passed a bill similar
when it relate to Firearms maybe compare
the two see if there's anything needs to
be looked at that would require an
independent violation of state law and
we can discuss that more give everyone
some time to digest it but that's
already the existing law so we do have
something on the books but maybe we can
put something in there to address liquor
enforcement as well if it's if they're
going to be involved we need to make
sure everyone's on the same page but I'm
you know I'm going to reserve know an
opinion way for
now so we're on do you guys want to go
for a couple more minutes or we said
we're going to be down around 12:30
originally trying to wrap up or do you
want to go until 1:00 uh smoking or
vaping cannabis in public I get some
that might get animated too so I that's
something we might want I think we just
we just go with it if we don't come with
the conclusion so no person shall smoke
or vaporized cannabis in an area
accessible to the public any person who
violates this SE section shall be guilty
of a violation maybe find not more than
$500 and shall forfeit all cannabis and
cannabis products so new Futures
suggested retaining this but add but
making the penalty
$100 and they said to be consistent with
the existing indoor smoking
act why would we want toce penalty um I
was reading that in um
Quebec this is a deterrent their minimum
is $1,200 and the maximum is
$4,500 in violation of this um
public I kind of wanted to be a
misdemeanor I a Class B misdemeanor so
if I can that's just me so my
recommendation was to change this from a
violation to a misdemeanor a be
misdemeanor on the First Defense and for
and have that same L leave it at $500 up
to right uh $500 it could still be $100
if they if the judge shows but then I
want um and a misdemeanor and up to
$2,000 for a second violation within
three
years I I would I would concur with that
and should we should we set a minimum
threshold and sh be not less than 500 or
not less than
250 I'd want to I'd want to leave it for
mitigating circumstances that a judge
may be able to consider so have maximum
fine the judge can adjust the fine based
on mitigating or aggravating
circumstances you're thank you I I don't
support further criminalization I think
we have a our leading Public Health uh
organization in New Hampshire actually
suggesting suggesting a decrease in the
penal
because I think they readily
uh understand that the evidence doesn't
show that criminalizing this type of
behavior is effective so I would fully
support new Future's recommendation to
put it down to $100 to be consistent
with existing law I just I wouldn't I
think the policy behind of a lot of our
work here is to do to have less people
uh be commit committing crimes and I
think we we're going against sort of the
policy thrust of this entire work if
we're going to just um create more
crimes here how do we deter public use I
just I mean I mean I I'll give you an
example I was in Salem M respond to you
hear me out in Salem Massachusetts I was
there and I parked in the parking garage
it was two weeks before Halloween real
fun in the stairway in the morning it's
my remind you it's like 9:00 in the
morning people are smoking in the
stairway in the par parking lot I'm
worried about walking into a court now
smelling like canvas that but I'm also
walking by then it's different people
when I'm going to leave a couple hours
later there's other people smoking that
so there's when I say public use is a
problem when I ate lunch outside I could
also smell it now there I'm just
pointing out is I don't think whatever
deterrent system they have going on
there is working very well and when I
say that that's happening it's Halloween
season there are families and kids
around everywhere so that's the biggest
concern I have is is a violation of a
$100 is that signif is that going to be
a deterrent I don't know I mean no so
just to I just was G to respond yeah I
was going to respond to that I mean so
new Futures as a Public Health
Organization they you know they are
aware of the effective Public Health
deterrent mechanisms and they are
recommending a reduction rather than
increasing of criminalization so both
recognizing what is an effective
deterrent is not criminalization and I I
would strongly you know if if there is
evidence that further criminalization is
an effective deterrent I would welcome
that and perhaps perhaps something the
effect of I think it's important if you
have
somebody especially if that person is uh
perhaps um has some Public public uh
service aspect to it maybe or has a uh
take a mandatory
class about
marijuana or something to that nature
but you need to get to coni conviction
and violation offenses you know what are
we what are we dealing with here um
believe me I'm to me it doesn't it
doesn't I'm going against probably my
colleagues but it doesn't feel right to
me that if the product is legal to use
but then we're making it a misdemeanor
if they use it twice in
public it doesn't you it's but this is
deterring public use you can own a car
but there's there's certain things you
can and can't do with it you can so I I
guess how do we the biggest concern I
hear is the states that have legalized
that the public use is absurd and the
states I've been to Old Orchard Beach I
was there for a week every everywhere I
kept count of how many times you could
smell it in one day again there's kids
everywhere I I mean I'm with my own kids
when you don't want to make public
policy on on you know sort of anecdotal
evidence you want to make public policy
based on evidence and if someone wants
to present the evidence that
criminalizing this is going to be a
deterrent that that I would welcome that
but like the whole idea of this work is
to decriminalize and pre and prevent
less crime so I could not support any
provision in here that would create a
brand new crime I can't Point all what's
the point of the $100 find if I
may yeah it's well it's consistent with
existing
law so I have a question for
Matt question Matt is yep yep so in a
public consumption area
if it's allowed and not
deterred unlike smoking which would
never have me possibly test positive for
controlled substance could you test
positive being in a public area and
somebody else is consuming and you're
inhaling is there any possible way for
you to test
positive I'm sorry Senator I can't
answer that question it seems unlikely
but I don't know okay someone's got
their head raised right behind I wasn't
I
was on this there's a doctor we'll ask
the
doctor on your specific question there's
one study of police officers who were
stationed at um who like who were doing
extra time at concerts and places where
there was outdoor consumption and I
think uh I I don't have the study with
me I think about a third of them
actually tested positive afterwards so
you do get secondhand smoke effects even
in outdoor spaces um that they're not
getting high but they sometimes s
suffered some effects I I did want to
note you may want to make sure that the
language uh doesn't allow smoking in any
place where tobacco is not currently
allowed so just to make sure it's
covering um workplaces um and other
settings that may not be public places
um but I do concur with Mr Mara and
other concerns about using community
service or other approaches that don't
get people into civil debt because you
know then if you don't can't pay the
fine and you end up losing your driver's
license so there're sometimes those
kinds of Cycles happening too so thank
you doctor so again my point of having a
a misdemeanor a B misdemeanor and a
misdemeanor is because you're putting at
risk the general public for possible
loss of job because I was around
somewhere and someone publicly smoking
and I test positive and I have a CDL
license and now I go get a I get
randomly drug tested by my employer and
now I lose my job because public
consumption occurred I want to deter
public consumption as much as possible
and make it a serious off fense so
people understand that you're not just
putting yourself at risk when it comes
to legalization you want a smoke in your
home have at it I don't care but the
idea that you can smoke publicly and
potentially cost a police officer's job
firemen is job a school teacher there
job because of randomized drug
testing I I think we need to be more um
en have more enforcement for that
reason and again I'm I'm I'm I agree
with what you're saying it's just to me
it just seems like it's a it's legal if
if it's legal to possess marij Iana and
then we we get somebody smoking it twice
it just seems out of proportion
that it's like open container
or but plus we'd have to get the uh plus
we'd have to get the marijuana tested MH
and we're back to the same situation
where we're arresting people we're
taking the product we're send it up to
the lab I just don't want to make a uh
and I don't it just seems out of
proportion I'm not it's already been
well the good news
is let me just think about
this in order to prevent people from
smoking in public how do we do it we say
we recommend don't do it but if there's
no penalty for doing it $100
fine I'm
just is that going to work and is that
worth the enfor the enforcement side
let's go up if people just walking
around smoking that because all we this
we're just saying no public use period
no exception right how do we stop people
from doing that being forced right I
think you have a graduated
fine and if they and if the people if
they don't pay the fine uh then you file
a motion for contempt would
then but to to me to me making like I
said it's if it's legal for somebody to
possess it and if there there's and we
catch them using it twice in a public
place it just it just as a police
officer just seems out of proportion but
that's the lack of deterrence they
they've done it now twice well that's
why you have to have the the the
graduated fines so I would support a
graduated fine over the creation of a
misdemeanor I I I could never support a
bill where we're doing further
criminalization it's already if you're
smoking in public what happens if you're
smoking a joint in public space right
now what
happens what's what's the penalty so so
M Mr chair I think if I may the the
question turns on what is necessary to
deter which is your point and uh how do
we balance that against uh whether or
not we criminalize or
decriminalize and um I think that the
the the best balance to go forward is to
start with a mandatory minimum fine that
is some that is
somewhat pricey enough to DET people if
it's not the cost of a gas tank tank of
gas it's not going to deter people well
you lose so I would start with a minimum
$250 fine and then work up from there as
a deterrent but you also lose your um
you have to forfeit your cannabis and
cannabis products that that when I put
that original I didn't write this exact
one but when I kind of came up with that
the for was part of the deterrence so
that would maybe help with your civil
fine but I I'm just wondering if a
person is going to be doing it multiple
times even if the first offense was a
violation why would the second one not
be be misdemeanor well I again I would
offer that you start at a minimum fine
of 250 the second fine could be
$500 and um and then whatever else if
there's a third offense then uh then you
might want to start obviously you've
developed history that the individual
involved in this is clearly flaunting
the law has no uh intention to follow
the law and after three times well
perhaps then you enter into the realm of
a be
misdemeanor but start with a minimum
find that somewhat consequential again
remember the in this statue that we're
still still leing the conversation says
maybe fine not more right so we're only
setting an upper limit to allow judges
who want to do diversion programs and
allow them to take a class you it's like
a motor vehicle violation right if I get
if I get a speeding ticket I get the
right to go take a class and the judge
will set aside my conviction if I want
this allows for that still to occur it
doesn't set a minimum mandatory it
allows for the fact that if you get
caught the first time you can be subject
up to a $500 fine but then up to the
judge to mitigate that if he chooses to
for whatever reason um he can choose to
have you take a class he could choose to
set a $100 fine versus a $500 fine the
judge will make that determination and
the same with the a misdemeanor again
here's a case where you've already been
warned that's against the law to do
something and then you do it again
anyway and so of course you want a
heavier penalty and a heavier fine for
that because you're just blatantly
ignoring the law after being warned that
it's it's already against the law to
smoke in public so yeah I want a heavier
fine and I want a heavier um inter
determination but again it still leaves
to it up to a $2,000 fine which is what
an a misdemeanor is allowed um but it
doesn't mandate that those fine levels
either I think um
we I think we'd also obviously have
concerns with uh criminalizing in this
respect um I think we would not love but
I think would support the graduated fine
idea I but I do think it's really
important to have to not allow for a
minimum uh but to have the not more than
language I when I was working in Alabama
we did a study on fines and fees with
the University of Alabama Birmingham um
and what we found was that over eight
and 10 people um who had court debt um
were actually giving up basic necess
ities like food and medicine because the
penalties for not paying down your court
debt like driver's license suspension
Etc were so severe and so I think you
know it's important to always have a
mechanism in there for the court to look
at whether someone can pay or not and to
have appropriate resp two
things I I I appreciate what's being
said here and I I understand I would
hate to see someone you know not feeding
their kids because they have to pay a
court fine to violate this law you
you're not doing it by accident you are
this is something that you have to go
out of your way to violate so I as much
as I sympathize from the financial
aspect you have to think about there's a
lot you had to do in your own mind to
violate this it's not something you just
do by accident with that being said if
it's a violation offense and I would
never do this maybe Senator we'll use
Senator Lang as an example if he's
smoking in a public place and a police
officer comes up and gives him his
ticket but he doesn't stop smoking what
happens no I'm just saying that he he
can just keep well you got to stop well
here's your second ticket or is it the
same act I don't know I mean I'm just
saying people are
smoking you can't I'm not even sure a
police officer can stop them in the
middle of what they're doing unless
there's some other way out of it that's
my point is that you can't really stop
it if it's only a violation offense yeah
you can take their stuff I guess you
have to like take everything out of the
hand well right it would be it would
result in the seizure of of any other
product that they may have on their
person
thank you Mr chair sorry sorry I stepped
out for a few minutes I might have
missed some of this conversation but my
question to you guys and maybe the chief
is what happens when someone's um
drinking open containers at Hampton
Beach they get their alcohol taken
what's the find for that what's the
crime it's it's $100 it should it should
be more that's an argument to be made
but I think I think the the $100 fine is
consistent with the alcohol that's where
something could come wrong with that I
think that's where it's coming together
at that point well what I'll say to that
is you drinking a beer at Hampton Beach
doesn't get me drunk but you smoking a
bunch of weed at Hampton Beach could get
me high and I don't want that in my
system and neither do a bunch of kids
playing at the beach um we we have an
obligation to make sure businesses
aren't affected in like say in
Manchester you go you go down on on the
strip in Manchester and stop by
businesses you you you sit outside
having dinner and you're getting high
you're you're getting secondhand smoke
100% that's what's going on right now I
go down there for dinner all the time so
we have an obligation to put strong
controls so that we we protect our state
I mean this isn't Alabama or California
with with all due respect this is New
Hampshire and we're here to protect our
citizens and keep them
safe State newshire Town pass
any Mr chair I think it's also uh
important to recognize that it's a
quality of life issue for the citizens
and the neighbors uh and the people that
are that are on the street above and
beyond uh the good Representatives
notion of of being
um um affected by secondhand smoke it's
a quality of life
issue and is that the quality of life
that we want for the public places in
the state of New Hampshire so and to
avoid that there needs to be some
consequential uh violations that deter
it otherwise we'll be invoking it and if
people learn that there are consequences
typically most people will avoid it if
the consequence is substantial than us
so so we all agree public smoking
shouldn't be allowed period the question
is is what what the penalty should be
all right I guess just this is not Bing
but as written is anyone fine with the
it's written right now no okay so we're
definitely going to change it um the new
do you mind just telling them the new
Futures draft they just recommend going
from 500 to 100 and I think it's
probably to be consistent with the
smoking indoor smoking act and is that
the that keeps the forfeiture provision
yeah who uh supports the no forfeiture I
mean the the $100 fine but with the
forat well no just just raise your hand
if you're you like that I'm not asking
you
to two uh we'll call it the uh Senator
Lang one the Mis theor
version and anyone who didn't is there
any um any recommendation for any
direction for us to go in I mean this
because we have you know the graduated
um the chief mayor the graduated
version but I but I think putting the
well so that my recommendation wasn't
Class A first right my first the first
violation is a B misdemeanor with up to
a $500 fine not a mandatory $500 fine
just up to the second violation within
three years would be um an a misdemeanor
with up to a $22,000 fund because you're
knowingly now committing a offense that
you've been told is not legal and you're
doing it anyway so that was my version
was uh be misdemeanor and I'd be okay
with dropping that to a violation with
$500 fine for the first offense so maybe
you so first offense would be a
violation all right we'll talk about the
dollar amount but we'll just no I'm just
I'm just I'm just brainstorming I'm not
saying I agree with
it the statute of limitations on
violation well okay just can you just
continue what you're saying well I it's
very odd to get a violation usually but
that what's going to happen is is if
someone's smoking in public they're
going to kind of get the violation right
way but if the first one is whether it's
500 100 we'll discuss that first one's a
violation second offense would that are
we okay with that being a b Miss no I we
have no here um is the any no we'd have
concerns with criminalizing even if for
a second offense what about a third
offense one option would be the current
statute around possession which I think
is three times the trip
right I mean how many time tickets can
you get in one week I think we really
see this through the same lens as
Senator Whitley that I've never seen
evidence that that's an effective
solution and all you're doing is putting
people into the criminal legal system
which there's robust data that shows
it's actually harmful to communities um
that puts people the criminal record to
makes them harder to get employment
housing Etc so I don't know why we'd
want to I'm just asking how many
violations can we make it to what
eventually becomes a misdemeanor within
like a certain time period you've
committed now 10 violations of this it's
still be just a violation I'm just
trying to say can we put something that
kind of satisfies one end in the other I
think the middle ground was the was the
your graduating scale but if the F's not
working clearly would it ever become a
Mis could be second offense third
offense I think in a three-year look
back the third one is by that point I
think is more than reasonable is it the
case with but what about with
smoking we're not putting this the same
as a a cigar or cigarette well well
you're talking about a deterrent right
yes but I think also the the public
health nicotine doesn't lead to
psychosis one causes impairment one
doesn't that's that's I mean I mean I I
have multiple work injuries from people
being high on the job no I I'm just
asking well but smoking causes lung
cancer I mean right and so but I think
what we I think my question is if the
real purpose is deterrence we need to
have the data to prove that's it's an
effective deterrent to criminalize the
behavior misdemeanor what's I got a good
idea because this conversation is very
helpful I just not agreeing why don't we
all kind of we all kind of know what our
thoughts are and we can flush that out
more at the next meeting so we're
clearly not going to come to a agreement
today and we can
all work on that is um when's our next
meeting
schedule just regarding this it's going
to be changed regardless of what's put
down no one on the no one raised their
hand that they supported
ezri that that was the only thing that
we were agreement on
well Senator abis and and Senator Lang
you've served in the house you know
there's about 80 to 100 people that will
go no just because you know what day of
the week is
it I I can Rel to why they may not be on
board with the first offense being a
misdemeanor I'm just wondering I mean a
second or third offense still not
graduating that high it's getting to a
point where but we'll we'll discuss that
more um next meeting is on for the 9th
is that am I right with that
go CH may I just say one thing if what
we want to do is protect our children
advertising limit on Advertising is
something that we've all agreed to about
role modeling and this is a form of
advertising when people are standing
there smoking weed or vaping weed in
public our children will be witness to
this do we not want to protect them no
it's not about that because I want to
protect them too I it is about that I'm
a mom and I no I just want to be clear
I'm a mom and I want to protect children
I don't want people smoking weed or
tobacco in my child's face it's
absolutely not about that I'm just
saying what is the most effective way to
do to do it we are prohibiting we are
prohibiting it that's exactly what we're
doing I'm a mom and so I I really reject
that notion that I don't want that
protection I have a 10-year-old I don't
want anyone smoking tobacco in his face
either nor do I want cannabis in his
face want a strong deterrent correct I I
want I want I want as an effective
deterrent and but I also don't want to
put people in jail and to have criminal
records for this because I know that's a
harm to to the Greater Community as well
but I really reject the notion that I
don't want to protect my children or
others I think that's very very unfair
so Dave I'll work with you and we'll see
what we can do about I graduated for
multiple offense stuff and see what we
can come up with for language for this
because it's obviously what's here isn't
isn't supported by anybody at all and so
it's going to be there's going to be a
change I'll work with um with Dave to
see if we can come up with some sort of
compromised language that'll that talks
about a graduated service I happen to
disagree with on this when you have a
knowingly offense I think it needs to be
a heavier penalty um but we can work on
what that do you mind including our our
Senator Whitley yeah because I I mean I
think in the end it is the it is us that
are going to vote on it we are the
elected officials and so I'm there's
absolutely no way that I would support
any sort of Bill that had a misdemeanor
built into it I I just have to say that
so so we we'll do that we'll we'll take
that up and I'll see if we can find I'll
see what we can come up with I think you
and I going to Just Disagree Becky on
that and and that's the nature of
politics sometimes but I do think there
needs to be enhanced penalties for a
second offense because of the knowingly
state after or even the fifth offense
maybe be enhanced I mean there should be
eventually that I think the violation if
it proves ineffective with an individual
there needs to be something
else but why don't we discuss that more
at um you know the next meeting and uh
so on for the n9th what make sure you
take a look at the single
I have I have a parent teacher
conference on the ninth but I will come
after that all right all right we
are